[Musique]
je n'ai
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tous qui voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce mardi 8 juin
emmanuel macron dénonce des faits isolés
d'individus ultra purs long et rappelle
la nécessité de respecter les fonctions
de la république réaction quelques
heures après avoir été giflé par un
homme lors d'un déplacement dans la
drôme où cet après midi deux hommes ont
été interpellés jean luc mélenchon a lui
réagi dans la foulée témoignant de sa
solidarité avec le président mais aussi
faisons le lien avec la polémique dont
il fait l'objet lui-même depuis deux
jours kamala harris poursuit sa tournée
en amérique centrale premier déplacement
à l'étranger depuis son arrivée à la
maison blanche
le guatemala a d'abord le guatemala a
d'abord puis aujourd'hui le mexique et
avec la très délicate question de
l'immigration clandestine
une visite de la vice-président
américaine censée s'appuyer sur la
promesse du président démocrate joe
biden d'adopter une politique migratoire
plus humaine que celle de donald trump
nous serons en direct depuis washington
[Musique]
dernière ligne droite de la
présidentielle au pérou le candidat de
la gauche radicale pedro castillo devant
sa rivale de droite keiko fujimori
fujimori retournement de situation alors
que la quasi-totalité des bulletins de
vote ont été dépouillés résultats très
serrés attendu
[Musique]
des images pour le moins inattendu en
déplacement à tain l'hermitage dans la
drôme emmanuel macron a reçu une gifle
de la part d'un homme lors d'un bain de
foule
la classe politiques de tous bords a
immédiatement réagi et apporte son
soutien au président pour plus de
précisions nous retrouvons tout de suite
monaco dès lors en direct de l'elysée
bonsoir monheim annuel macron a été donc
agressé lors d'un bain de foule cet
après midi
oui c'était un déplacement qui avait
très bien commencé presque dans une
ambiance de cartes postales pour le
président de la république dans la drôle
il a voulu aller au contact c'est un
exercice qu'il apprécie les bains de
foule il en a l'habitude c'est là qu'un
homme lui a attrapé le bras et l'a giflé
en criant à bas la macro ni montjoie
saint denis qui est un slogan d'extrême
droite arié royalistes le président la
république a commenté il a parlé de
faits isolés de personnes ultra violente
pour l'instant deux personnes ont été
interpellées puis vous l'imaginez toute
la classe politique est unanime il
condamne tous cette agression jean
castex le premier ministre en a appelé
un sursaut républicain écoutez le
vers le chef de l'état c'est tout
simplement la démocratie qu'est viser la
démocratie la démocratie
mesdames et messieurs les députés
la démocratie et vous en est
l'illustration c'est le sait le débat
c'est le dialogue c'est la confrontation
d'idées c'est l'expression de désaccord
légitime
bien entendu mais ça ne peut en aucun
cas être la violence l'agression verbale
et encore moins l'agression physique
j'en appelle à un sursaut républicain
nous sommes tous concernés
il en va des fondements de notre
démocratie je vous remercie et cette
agression elle intervient à un moment
assez particulier puisque depuis
dimanche jean luc mélenchon est au coeur
d'une polémique pour des propos qu'il a
eu il a été accusé de complotisme il a
alerté dénoncé les menaces dont il
faisait l'objet de la part de l'extrême
droite ce matin juste avant l'agression
emmanuel macron a condamné à ces menaces
et juste après l agression à cet après
midi jean luc mélenchon a immédiatement
réagi en faisant écho de sa situation
écoutez le cette fois-ci vous commencez
à comprendre que les violents passe à
l'acte je suis solidaire du président
est ce que maintenant le gouvernement va
enfin déclencher la justice contre papa
si tôt et sa vidéo d'appel au meurtre et
mona comment a réagi l'entourage du
président de la république
et bien pour le moment lantoine jeu
président de la république minimise il
parle plutôt de tentatives de j -p
d'ailleurs le président de la république
a continué sa journée comme si rien ne
s'était passé
mais ce n'est pas la première fois qu'un
président est pris pour cible
souvenez-vous en 2011 nicolas sarkozy
avait été lui aussi attrapé violemment
par le col à brax cette agression elle
met en exergue une violence que les
politiques dénoncent depuis plusieurs
jours et elle c'est un signe aussi que
la crise sociale et sociétale est
exacerbée dans notre pays à quelques
mois de la campagne présidentielle
merci madame ou dès lors en direct de
l'elysée et condamnations donc unanime
de la classe politique on l'a entendu
cet après-midi après cette gifle le
premier ministre a pris la parole à
l'assemblée on vient de l'écouté jean
castex qui demande un sursaut
républicain le pays devient-il de plus
en plus violent la démocratie et l
attaquer comme l'ont quitterait de
nombreux médias ce qu'elle se délite
cette agression est elle vraiment un
fait isolé comme le dit ce soir emmanuel
macron c'est l'objet de notre décryptage
ce soir
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler mais dieu est
un rédacteur en chef de la radio
h2o bonsoir jean pierre colombiès porte
parole du syndicat de policier
indépendant lui pmi et puis enfin alexis
paulin notre éditorialiste bonsoir à
tous les trois merci d'être avec nous
sur l'antenne berthet france emmanuel
macron qui est donc giflé cet après midi
par un individu dans la drôme un autre
filmé la scène
on va revoir tout d'abord les images il
y avait trop dit
[Musique]
petit froid effectivement lors de ce
petit bain de foule incidents dont qui
s'est déroulé à lors de ce fameux tour
de france du président c'est un geste et
qui vous a choqué mathieu hutin où il
m'a choqué comme je crois il a choqué
tous les français qui sont attachés à
l'état de droit à l'institution à ce
pays a c'est république à toutes ces
valeurs à tout son passé
on va pas refaire l'histoire de france
mais on ne peut pas et je crois que là
la condamnation unanime de toute la
classe politique et représente bien ce
sentiment qui doit être ce soir partagée
par tous et s'il n'est pas partagée par
tous j'invite ceux qui ne partagent pas
à se remettre en question on ne peut pas
giflé dans ce pays un professeur un
policier où le chef de l'état
quoi qu'on ne soit pas d'accord avec lui
ou avec sa politique
les opposants emmanuel macron sont
nombreux ok mais rien ne justifie la
violence et rien ne justifiera jamais la
violence
je vais m'adresser aux policiers jean
pierre colombiès clairement ça pose un
problème de sécurité
quand on revoit cette scène quand même
choquant effectivement d'un président de
la république qui se fait gifler en
pleine rue bonsoir c'est choquant mais
surtout il je crois que quand vous
revoyez les images il faut bien se
rendre compte que le président lui-même
commet une petite erreur en courant
comme il le fait et en déstabilisant
déséquilibrant son propre service de
sécurité gens que c'est quelque chose
qui n'est pas spécifié spécialement à
faire on met tout le monde en danger
dans l'histoire c'est pas très adroite
de mon point de vue il faut jamais
perdre de vue que vous êtes face à des
gens que vous ne connaissez pas n'est
pas nécessairement des gens qui vous
apprécie qui vous aiment ça c'est le
premier point donc effectivement il ya
là toujours danger naturellement danger
à ce qu'une personnalité politique à
evere des bains de foule
c'est un cauchemar pour les services de
sécurité parce que bien évidemment la
potentialité du mauvais geste existe
elle est là les exemples sont nombreux
vous avez eu manuel valls qui avait pris
une gifle aussi nicolas sarkozy bien
entendu françois hollande qui avait pris
de la farine
donc là je dirais la zéro faille le
principe de la faille 0 duché de
l'incidence zéro ça n'existe pas et ça
ne peut pas exister dès lors que vous
prenez une initiative personnelle qui
vous met 2
de fait en danger et je pense que
l'initiative d'un débat cours de ce
point de vue là été très maladroite
parce qu'on le voit courir et de fait on
voit tous ces agents de sécurité courir
derrière lui c'était probablement pas
prévu et à partir de ce moment là bas
vous créez vous mettez vous même tout
seul en situation périlleuse
bon là il se trouve qu'il ya un individu
lui a mis une gifle ça aurait pu être
beaucoup plus grave je pense qu'en dites
vous dire heureusement ça dès qu'une
gifle ça aurait pu être un coup de
couteau ça aurait pu être tout autre
chose dans l'histoire c'est pas la
première fois que ça arrive je rappelle
quand même pour mémoire que deux
présidents français ont été assassinés
c'est autre chose que les gifles sadi
carnot paul doumer par des anarchistes
par des activistes politiques donc pas
la violence en politique elle est là
elle est inhérente à ce milieu est
inhérente au discours violent qu'on a
tendance à entendre en ce moment un peu
trop souvent de de notre point de vue
petit juste une petite précision du pays
n'est pas un syndicat c'est une
association de policiers indépendant
voilà bon j'ai pas monopoliser la parole
mais voilà il y aurait beaucoup de
choses à dire sur ce qui est à la fois
ça y est vous l'aurez à nouveau qu'est
ce qu'elle circule entre vous trois
messieurs alexis poulain
monsieur columbia they know me dire il
ya eu évidemment des assassinats
politiques il n'empêche ce cette gifle a
toujours un côté un petit peu humiliant
c'est vrai que c'est humiliant une gifle
d'ailleurs on n'a pas forcément droit de
frapper les enfants c'est interdit par
par la loi donc est ce qu'il ya une
désacralisation de la fonction qui
imagine le général de gaulle se faire
gifler dans la rue oui je crois que il
ya là finalement le l'aboutissement de
de l'incarnation du pouvoir par emmanuel
macron c'est-à-dire ultra personnalisé
ultra centralisé qui incarne tout le
qu'il vienne me chercher qui est resté
dans les esprits
évidemment que il ya encore des gens qui
veulent aller le chercher même si je
dénéral mans il ya trois cordon de
gendarmerie devant lui et puis c'est
vrai que la violence est inacceptable et
on a vu la classe politique unanimement
condamné cette gifle mais emmanuel
macron un car d'une certaine façon le
président de la violence c'est lui qui a
choisi d'utiliser les forces de l'ordre
avec ses ailes bdc lacrymo ses nombreux
mutilé éborgné lors des manifestations
des gilet jaune c'est lui qui choisi la
confrontation avec le peuple français
par le 49 3 et au delà qui va remettre
la réforme des retraites sur la table
c'est lui qui a toujours cette petite
phrase méprisante et qui giflent
finalement de manière symbolique les
français systématiquement lors de ses
prises de parole est là il reçoit cette
gifle effectivement condamnable
puisqu'il est le chef de l'état
puisqu'il incarne l'autorité même la clé
de voûte des institutions mais on se
rappelle des manuels macron en ses rangs
des lascars lors de ses voyages dans les
îles la fête de la musique sur le perron
de l'elysée la façon qu'il a eue de
lui-même désacraliser cette fonction
l'interview avec mc fly et carlito sur
youtube comment voulez vous après qu'un
président soit respectée je crois qu'il
ya là vraiment à hiatus énorme entre ce
qu'avait premier modèle macron c'est à
dire ceux c'est rareté revenir sur un
nuage jupitérien de la fonction elysée n
est en réalité ce qu'il fait lui c'est à
dire une campagne de communication et de
marketing permanente
donc ils s'abaissent à ce niveau là et
voilà qu'arrive cette gifle serait-il ça
aurait pu être bien plus grave parce
qu'effectivement comme vous venez de le
dire
il a un peu mis en défaut son système de
sécurité de protection rapprochée et
donc c'est une leçon pour tout le monde
mais ça dit aussi
beaucoup du niveau en fait de violence
décomplexée et d'ébullition de la
société française et je crois qu'il a
une parole là qu'il devrait lui incarne
emmanuel macron lors de son discours du
14 juillet mais un retour à la raison de
tout le monde on ne peut pas avoir d'un
côté un youtuber comme papa sitôt qui va
se mettre en scène en train de tirer sur
des mannequins ou bien des discours de
haine largement partagée et en même
temps c'est ce fameux en même temps
macro nist avoir une politique de la
violence donc il va falloir calmer les
esprits que cette campagne qui commence
pour 2022 se passe dans des conditions
sereines
sinon le risque c'est effectivement un
attentat un meurtre politique on n'est
pas à l'abri de ça et malheureusement je
crois qu'il ya ce côté à fleur de peau
de la société française et emmanuel
macron ne fait rien pour accrocher les
wagons au contraire il divise toujours
et encore alors le chef de l'état lui
préfère relativiser ce soir il réagi il
dénonce des faits isolés d'individus
ultra violent le mot est quand même
prononcée ces individus ultra violent il
appelle à respecter la république il ne
lâchera rien de ce combat dit-il m e u
tin vous êtes d'accord avec cette
analyse du chef de l'état un fait isolé
d'individus ultra violent je crois que
le chef de l'état veut pas content or
cet événement en étendard ce sera ma
réponse à votre question je voudrais
revenir sur les propos d'alexis poulain
les deux minutes
il demande que l'appel à la révolution
propos monsieur l'historia liste je
voudrais vous appeler au calme et d'une
façon générale je ne suis personne pour
le faire mais cette politique tender
commence à me donner envie de vomir
quand est ce qu'on va siffler la fin de
la récré dans ce pays
vous pouvez reprocher emmanuel macron
d'art fait toutes les erreurs de
communication de la terre hockey pouvait
lui reprocher le 49-3 pouvait lui
reprocher d'avoir envoyé des forces de
l'ordre les matraques contre les gilet
jaune
moi je reviendrai pas sur ça on va pas
réécrire l'histoire mais ce soir on ne
peut pas banaliser cet acte de gif qui
est un faits violents pour commencer
votre votre édito en disant oui une
gifle c'est interdit on peut plus
ordonner aux enfants c'est un fait
violence est il derrière ces noms mais
l'éditeur d'alexis blanc j'ai bien
compris stéphanie de rue on commence en
disant c'est comme la gifle imaginaire
qu'il a donné aux français sauf que si
la gifle imaginaire kalki qu'il a donné
aux français existe elle est imaginaire
là on a le chef de l'état qui représente
le hac le pays tout entier qui a été au
violon t on on va laisser répondre à
l'excès poulain vous répondre et ce que
vous l'avez interpellé tout à l'heure on
va faire un petit détour pardonnez-moi
lexsi on vous donnera la parole
évidemment vous manquerez pas de
répondait m maintenant je faisais juste
référence au fait que l'histoire des
enfants c'était moi c'était pas l'édito
de d'alexis poulin et ça n'avait voilà
aucune espèce de l'analyse dedans mais
bon je voudrais vous faire réagir
justement sur cette question de la
violence sur cette règle ce tour de
david lisnard le maire les républicains
de cadre écouté le combat politique se
fait par les idées les élections la
gifle reçue par une manuelle macron est
un acte minable et honteux pour notre
pays
la multiplication des violences y
compris contre des représentants des
institutions devient un fait de société
majeur évidemment grave c'est ça qui
vous énerve jean pierre colombier cette
multiplication des violences vous n'êtes
pas nécessairement d'accord avec cette
analyse du maire de cannes vous savez
que je comprends pas trop des gens ce
qui vient d'être dit il a juste eu
préalablement puisque j'ai écouté il ya
peu de temps sur une autre antenne
madame prisca thévenot qui disent une
chose assez surprenante elle visé ce qui
vient de se passer ni ni excusable ni
ne faut pas chercher d'excusés ni à le
comprendre on a déjà entendu ça
plusieurs fois et c'est un discours moi
qui me gêne quand on n'est pas là pour
excuser une gifle et une gifle c'est un
délit point barre par contre dire on n'a
pas cherché à comprendre c'est se voiler
la face et ne pas regarder les choses en
face
il se trouve que dans le cadre de ma
mission de porte parole de cette
association du pnud
nous avons rencontré beaucoup de monde
des élus de tous bords des politiques
sur tous les points où nous rendions et
aussi j'ai rencontré dg des jaunes tout
simplement d'aimer membres de la société
de la pop et sade de la population ça
s'appelle le peuple tout simplement skis
étaient symptomatiques ci était
révélateur c'est la haine la haine
viscérale le conte une qu'à une certaine
partie de la population à l'égard non
pas de l'état
il faut bien faire la part des choses
mais à l'égard d' emmanuel macron il ne
faut pas mélanger les choses
il y à une crispation fondamental dans
ce pays aujourd'hui ça se ressent on
peut très bien de ne pas le choix vous
faire semblant de ne pas le voir mais
c'est une réalité il y à une partie de
la population qui est viscéralement
opposé à monsieur macron pour des
raisons qui leur sont propres diverses
est-ce que ça doit aller jusqu'à la
violence on n'est pas là pour la
justifier bien évidemment il faut la
comprendre il faut essayer d'analyser
les mécanismes qui conduisent
aujourd'hui avoir une rupture totale en
une personnalité qui est supposé
incarner l'état de droit l'état
républicain est que plus personne ne
respecte me semble respectée aujourd'hui
si on refuse de se poser cette question
c'est qu'on n'a rien compris à la
politique est sûre je suis d'avoir de
dire quand madame thévenoud qui est une
porte parole de la république en marche
dit qu'il ne faut pas chercher à
comprendre c'est bien dommage parce
qu'elle est quand même politique et
c'est un personnel politique et b ci
sont aussi son jardin quelque part en
tant qu'élu d'essayer de comprendre ce
qui se passe dans un pays ont
aujourd'hui les fractures qui existent
elles sont profondes et elles sont
viscéral donc il faut être très vigilant
très attention et l'avertissement pour
tout le monde et pas simplement pour
effectivement les prises de paroles très
maladroite parfois que qui sont
réservées au nom du gouvernement mais
aussi à la gauche l'extrême gauche ou à
la droite ou d'extrême droite n'est
facile derniers temps faut admettre que
les déclarations de monsieur mélenchon
ont été particulièrement incisive acide
bon j'ai qualifierait même de mal à
droite on a d'ailleurs du mal à savoir
où il veut en venir mais là
quand je suis désolé l'attitude du
gouvernement au travers de certains de
ses composantes a été incompréhensible
de mon point de vue et si aujourd'hui on
en est là c'est parce qu'il ya eu je me
souviens quand même de l'épisode des
gilet jaune pendant plus quasiment un an
il ya eu des prises de position des
déclarations de castanet rld et d'autres
qui ont été mes mais d'une provocation
insupportable aujourd'hui ne nous
trompons pas une partie de la population
l'a peut-être la france profonde appelez
ça comme vous voulez ne supporte plus la
personnalité du président il va falloir
vraiment intégré cette donnée parce que
c'est peut-être pas le dernier incident
il faudrait pas que ce soit beaucoup
plus grave parce que là pour le coup
c'est tout l'équilibré publique est en
danger à l'excès pour la wii mais
absolument et moi j'ai appelé pas du
tout à la révolution j'ai appelé à la
retour à la raison au retour au calme et
en disant justement que il faut
comprendre ce geste ne pas l'excuser
bien sûr c'est inexcusable
parce que c'est un problème évidemment
on comment on en arrive là qu'un
président de la république se fait
gifler dans la rue alors il vous le
rappeler il ya eu nicolas sarkozy et
françois hollande etc
mais c'est une lente descente finalement
d'un d'un piédestal ou même du respect
en les institutions mais ça veut dire
que le dialogue est rompu quelque part
où est la démocratie représentative
c'est cette élection finalement 2017 on
se dit d'accord il est élu mais au lieu
de rassembler il va faire une politique
qui va cliver et ce clivage arrive
effectivement ce que vous venez de dire
avec une france qui n'ont pas des france
qui ne se parlent plus une archipel
isation total et la campagne de 2022
comme ans sur cet archipel isation en
allant parler à quelqu'un il ya
quelqu'un d'autre donc hors de question
bien entendu de de faire l'éloge de la
violence au contraire elle est
condamnable et j'ai toujours condamné
toutes les violences
et c'est bien ça le problème c'est qu'on
ne peut pas d'un côté condamné la
violence de la gifle sur un président en
effet faire l'impasse sur la violence
qui s'est déversée violence d'état cette
fois ci sur les manifestants des gilet
jaune
sans ça il n'y a pas de concorde et
c'est bien ça le problème est que dit la
porte parole de la macro ni et bien
écoutez on ne va pas excusé on ne va pas
essayer de comprendre
c'est scandaleux c'est à dire que là
c'est exactement d'ailleurs ce que fait
en marche depuis le début des grands
blabla ddd grande concertation pour
entendre et écouter les français et puis
ensuite ils font n'importe quoi
les cahiers de doléances des gilets
jaunes c'est simple ils dorment dans les
sous sol de la bibliothèque nationale de
france c'est tout ils n'ont jamais été
lu écouté ou quoi que ce soit et puis on
a eu droit à une conférence de presse à
la fin des modèles mâcon donc c'est
cette captation de la parole finale
ce jeu électoral tous les cinq ans où on
va choisir un candidat plutôt qu'un
autre alors qu'entre temps on n'a
vraiment pas pas les moyens de faire une
démocratie directe où une démocratie
partager il est là le problème en france
c'est que la démocratie représentative
est totalement en panne et qu'on ne
veulent pas le voir c'est grave parce
que ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
des franges de plus en plus grande de la
population vont ce nom pas dépolitiser
maison se radicaliser et arriver à des
solutions violentes donc si on veut
revenir évidemment dans un système type
années 30 où des milices des sections
vont se mettre en place et c'est un peu
déjà le cas avec les appels à la
sédition qu'on a vu dans les corps armés
c'est extrêmement grave et je crois que
c'est pas pris à la hauteur de la
gravité et puis après on va montrer du
doigt un les islamo gauchiste d'à côté
les républicains de l'autre les
gauchistes ou les gens d'aimer enfin la
politique ce n'est pas montrée du doigt
et se frapper c'est débattre et c'est le
débat qui manque en france aujourd'hui
c'est que la parole elle est monopolisée
elle est interdite donc il faut remettre
un lieu de parole et malheureusement je
ne vois pas aujourd'hui et c'est bien la
campagne des campagnes politiques qui
permettent à la parole de s'échanger
donc il va falloir trouver une solution
pour que la parole et pour que cette
violence là ne devienne pas violente
mais devienne un fait politique mais une
politique démocratique républicaine où
chacun peut entendre les arguments des
autres voilà tout simplement ce que je
voulais dire effectivement que société
privée fracturait je vous propose
d'écouter la réaction d'eric coquerel de
la france soumise qui lui clairement
disait l'extrême droite
exactement ce qu'est papa si tout ça y
est vous la prenez au sérieux la
violence d'extrême droite maintenant
solidaire du président mathieu mettant
votre réaction c'était la bonne réaction
parce que cette correction d'eric
coquerel est assez dissonante par
rapport au reste de la classe politique
qui a tout simplement condamné unanime
aulas est vrai qu eric coquerel rejette
la faute sur les royalistes sur
l'extrême droite être que c'était la
bonne réponse aujourd'hui
ils rejettent la faute parce qu'il est à
cran eric coquerel jeu luc mélenchon
mélenchon a été pris juste un appel au
meurtre qui a été publié sur sur les
réseaux sociaux ont sonné ému rapidement
et puis maintenant à la gifle de macron
qui passent au premier plan et on a
oublié on oublier ça néanmoins eric
coquerel rappelle qu'il est solidaire
avec
manuel maquereau ou en tout cas le camp
la france insoumise l'a fait donc
peut-être que la réponse tout cas la
réponse de fond est là sur la forme
effectivement il est il est travaillé
très agacé eric coquerel
mais pardon mais on en revient à quoi à
chaque fois on en revient au digital on
revient aux réseaux sociaux
papa si tôt et tous les autres quand est
ce qu'on va dans ce pays
faire le ménage mais alors ça parce
qu'avec ce que vous disiez messieurs
juste avant le débat public est en panne
on n'écoute plus les gens les médias
mainstream et les grands éditorialistes
qui donc sont pas là ce soir se permet
de critiquer ouvertement ou de mépriser
ouvertement les petites gens qui sur les
ronds-points parle avec des mots de tous
les jours
moi je les reçois mon micro ici dans ma
radio locale j'avais deux gilet jaune
qui sont candidats au départemental il
ya une demi-heure ici qui me disais bon
nous on n'a pas de programme
on puisera dans le programme des autres
parce que nous on fait ce qu'on veut
faire c'est demander aux gens si ça leur
va
mais quand vous nous expliquer ça sur
une chaîne nationale tout le monde se
marre parce qu'effectivement le monsieur
il a un physique un peu atypique peut
être ou alors une façon de parler
bizarre donc ici c'est mieux de se
moquer je crois qu'il ya un moment dans
ce pays va falloir que le mot respect et
reprennent tout son sens et sa priorité
qu il va falloir qu'on réapprenne à
s'écouter mais ça marche dans les deux
sens
dire que il faut que les gens qui
aujourd'hui appellent à la haine contre
le président met leurs postes des
réseaux sociaux en pause pour écouter le
président pour ensuite plus parler lire
tonné monsieur présent vous nous avez
pas écouté que ce soit celui ci ou un
autre un peu importe mais il va falloir
que le débat reprenne toute sa place et
qu'enfin dans ce pays puisque depuis dix
quinze vingt ans digitalement parlant
les réseaux sociaux les plateformes les
gaffes à rien n'a été fait tout a été
oublié dans la législation
l'état français est incapable de faire
le ménage
alors je ne vous dis pas de censure et
moi je suis un fervent défenseur de la
liberté d'expression
j'ai mis tout le monde à la règle
d'égalité sur le temps de parole pour le
départemental tout le monde aura douze
minutes
donc non ne censureront pas c'est
royalistes par contre donnant leur un
espace d'expression de mettons l'heure
des contradicteurs en face par contre
tout appel à la violence doit être
sévèrement condamnés et surtout
sévèrement punis sévèrement punis et
c'est la même chose que c'est la même
chose dans la ferme il a c'est la même
chose à chaque fois en fait moi c'est ce
que j'appelle la politique think there
c'est à dire que toutes les semaines on
est reparti qu'un nouveau buzz
sociaux alors en plus là c'est super on
est sur une fête séquence de macron qui
sort de sa rencontre avec les lycéens il
ya aucune caméra parce que ça devait pas
être une séquence autorisés dont il ya
aucun média mainstream
donc c'est une image twitter avec des
gens il ya des barrières vauban
qu'est ce que c'est que cette politique
de caniveau basée sur la communication
d'un président qui arrive en courant oui
les tories sont partagés ils sont
partagés entre cette personne qui
connaît qui ont commis un acte violent
et puis ce président qui se prend pour
starsky et hutch stop le débat d'idées
maintenant arrêtons arrêtons ces cultes
les réseaux sociaux twitter parce qu'on
arrive au bout du débat et le mot de la
fin je vois que jean piat colombien
souhaiterais réagir et donc conclure
s'il vous plaît merci conclure j'ai pas
cette prétention mais alors pour le
débat d'idées justement il se trouve que
je suis signataire d'une d'une tribune
de policiers retraités qui sont libérés
de tout de toute contrainte quelle
qu'elle soit et en réaction justement
avec toutes les déclarations de dupond
moretti darmana et j'en passe et des
meilleurs projets sur notre fil au pathé
patachon par rapport justement à la
manifestation qui dit qu'il ya eu la
manifestation des policiers en colère
qui pour moi était dramatique parce
qu'elle ne débouchaient sur rien il faut
savoir que parallèlement des lois que je
qualifierais comme des lois scélérates
ont été votées et sergio est ce que vous
disiez finalement les uns les autres
c'est qu'on n'écoute personne
c'est que vous avez trente mille
personnes sur une place publique face à
l'assemblée nationale qui crient leur
désespoir qui vous expliquent que rien
ne va plus avec des arguments auxquels
je ne raccroche pas nécessairement parce
que le débat est beaucoup plus complexe
que ça mais au final on laisse
s'égosiller les gens et pendant ce temps
là on vote des lois on se fiche
éperdument de ce que peuvent penser les
uns les autres
il faut pas s'imaginer que ça va passer
comme ça ne faut quand même pas perdre
si on s'intéresse un peu à la politique
de ce pays qu emmanuel macron est élu
avec 15% des voix des inscrits c'est à
dire quasiment rien donc le pays
ne nous y trompons pas le pays n'est pas
dans le fond macro nist il subit cette
politique
alors maintenant la faute à qui vous
voulez réaliser et les autres viennent
de le dire à une déshérence totale du
dialogue politique
il n'y a plus de parti politique dans ce
pays j'ai envie de dire que globalement
il ya même plus de débats d'idées voilà
on ne sait pas où on en est donc
effectivement la violence risque
d'émerger à tous les niveaux parce que
comme vous voulez là encore de le dire
les réseaux sociaux font la loi et c'est
pas en inventant les deux énergumènes a
des visées que ça va arranger les choses
c'est une cata de mon point de vue
c'est une catastrophe parce que vous le
légitimer le débat justement qui a lieu
sur la toile et vous légitimez une forme
de parole un petit peu transgressives ou
libertaire enfin bon moi je moi je veux
bien tout ça mais tout ça est hors de
contrôle surtout merci beaucoup en tout
cas tous les 3 alexis poulain mathieu
hutin jean-pierre columbia sa voix était
avec nous en direct sur rt france rester
avec nous dans quelques instants nous
parlons du déplacement officiel de
camada harris en amérique centrale la
vice-présidente américaine aujourd'hui
au mexique sur l'épineuse question de
l'immigration clandestine et puis
direction le pérou ont candidat de la
gauche radicale et drouot castillo
devance sa rivale de la droite keiko
fujimori
fujimori le pays dans l'attenté des
résultats officiels
[Musique]
en féminines ici des commis tous les
deux à trois jours en france
actuellement
pourquoi il joue ton encore à protéger
totalement les femmes on dit souvent aux
femmes
oser en parler briser le silence nous
savons que seulement 18 19 % des femmes
révèle les violences qu'elles subissent
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya 80% de femmes
qui ne révèle pas les violences qu'elles
subissent aux forces de sécurité
donc celle qui rêvait il faut vraiment
les croix et les protéger souvent on met
toute la responsabilité sur la victime
c'est la question de quels sont les
moyens que l'agresseur a mis en oeuvre
qui doit être posée et la loi nous dit
très clairement et souvent on détourne
la loi par cette histoire de
consentement on voit bien qu'on est
quand même encore très loin très loin de
ce qui est nécessaire pour vraiment
pouvoir avoir les moyens de protéger les
femmes
chaque jour en politique des milliers de
parties d'échecs se jouer mais les
règles ne sont pas toujours respectées
les couleurs changent de camp les pions
prennent la place des rois de films
stratégies peuvent porter des résultats
inattendus
[Musique]
un coup décisif ne fait que repousser la
victoire
[Musique]
monsieur les chômeurs et chaque semaine
dans l'échiquier mondial nous
analyserons les coups les plus complexes
du jeu politique internationale
à bientôt sur rt france
chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes coups
politiques n'a jamais été obligé de dire
la vérité d idée courageuse des mots qui
comptent en soi vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche l'extrême
internet
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
20h30 soyez les bienvenus en direction
rt france si vous nous rejoignez le
président des états unis joe biden
entame demain une tournée européenne
avant une rencontre avec son homologue
russe vladimir poutine ce sera le 16
juin à genève
la vice présidente elle poursuit sa
tournée en amérique centrale kamala
harris qui est en charge du dossier de
l'immigration clandestine
pour plus de précisions on retrouve
notre reporter thomas bonnet en direct
de washington bonsoir se bat pour son
premier déplacement officiel en tant que
vice présidente
kamala harris s'est donc rendu au
guatemala un voyage visant à aborder la
thématique de l'immigration
oui ça a été assez compliqué puisque à
peine l'avion parti et bien il a dû
faire demi-tour seulement 30 minutes
après le départ il y avait eu un petit
problème technique qui est donc
finalement kamala harris est bel et bien
arrivé au guatemala hier où l'accueil
était plutôt froid il y avait notamment
des slogans pro donald trump à son
arrivée et puis encore une fois au
niveau anecdote il ya eu un petit rappel
à l'ordre de la part du président du
guatemala sur le protocole puisqu'à
l'issue de son discours kamala harris
avait tout simplement oublié de remettre
son masque ça c'est donc pour la forme
un premier déplacement mouvementée sur
le thème donc de l'immigration et où il
lui a été aussi reproché de ne pas se
rendre en personne à la frontière entre
les etats-unis et le mexique elle a
répondu justement à ces interrogations
lors d'une interview elle a répondu
qu'elle n'était pas non plus aller en
europe une réponse assez étrange qui a
évidemment pas trop convaincu les
observateurs alors sur le fond à kamala
harris était là pour délivrer un message
fort dissuader les candidats au départ
de se rendre aux états unis on écoute
kamala harris la vice présidente
je tiens souligné que l'objectif de
notre travail est d'aider les
guatémaltèques a retrouvé l'espoir chez
eux
je vais également être clair avec les
gens de cette région qui envisage de
faire ce voyage dangereux jusqu'à la
frontière américano-mexicaine
ne venez pas
ne venez pas les états unis continueront
d'appliquer nos lois et de sécuriser nos
frontières
il existe des méthodes légales par
lesquels la migration peut et doit se
produire
c'est l'une de nos priorités nous
décourageons la migration illégale et je
crois que si vous venez à notre
frontière
vous serez refoulés à touba ce discours
qui a provoqué énormément de critiques
mais kamala harris persiste et signe
oui car il faut bien avouer que ce
discours ressemble finalement à celui
qu'avait donald trump
à l'époque on comprend que le but est de
corriger l'interprétation qui a été fait
de l'élection de joe biden en amérique
centrale parce que dans la région
beaucoup y ont vu un signe d'espoir sur
un possible assouplissement des règles
d'entrée aux états unis résultats il y à
un afflux massif de migrants ces
derniers mois avec par exemple 172
milles personnes qui ont été arrêtés à
la frontière
rien qu'au mois de mars c'est donc pour
tenter d'endiguer ce phénomène que
kamala harris a tenu ce discours mais
comme on pouvait s'en douter les
réactions notamment dans l'ailé gauche
du parti démocrate ne sont ne se sont
pas fait attendre
voici par exemple ce cas twittait
alexandra occasion cortese c'est
décevant avoir premièrement demander
l'asile à n'importe quelle frontière
américaine est une méthode d'arrivée
100% légal
deuxièmement les états unis ont passé
des décennies a contribué au changement
de régime et à la déstabilisation en
amérique latine nous ne pouvons pas nous
empêcher de mettre le feu à la maison de
quelqu'un et de lui reprocher ensuite de
s'enfuir mais kamala harris assume sa
position elle persiste et signe en
expliquant vouloir s'attaquer aux causes
profondes de l'immigration c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'elle a signé un
certain nombre d'accords aujourd'hui
lors de sa leçon lors de son déplacement
au mexique n'est en tout cas ce
positionnement est d'autant plus heureux
mise en cause qu'il est finalement très
éloigné de celui qui était le sien il y
encore quelques années en arrière voici
par exemple un tweet posté en janvier
2017 ou kamala harris affirme alors que
tout le monde est bienvenu aux états
unis s'opposant à ce moment là la
construction du mur à la frontière un
tweet qui vous pouvez l'imaginer a été
très largement repris ces dernières
heures pour questionner cet étrange
virage de la part de la vice-présidente
des etats-unis d'ailleurs l avenir du
mur est aussi une épine dans le pied de
la nouvelle administration puisque les
travaux ont cessé certes depuis
l'élection de joe biden mais le
financement et les matériaux sont déjà
là et la situation migratoire étant
finalement très compliqué de joe biden
se laisse du temps pour trancher
l'avenir donc de semur la preuve que la
thématique de l'immigration est bel et
bien le premier grand défi de la
nouvelle administration de la maison
blanche merci ça va donner en direct de
washington élections présidentielles aux
résultats très serrés au pérou d'abord
en tête des dépouillements keiko
fujimori la candidate de la droite
populiste a été finalement rattrapé hier
soir par son rival de la gauche radicale
pedro castillo lé vote en provenance dé
campagne reculée de l'amazonie aurait
fait la différence
les résultats définitifs sont attendus
dans les prochaines heures grégoire bon
c c'est un scrutin au suspense
hitchcockien que vivent les péruviens
depuis dimanche la candidate de la
droite populiste keiko fujimori semblait
se diriger vers une victoire si l'on se
fiait à la première partie du
dépouillement
la fille de l'ancien président alberto
fujimori aujourd'hui en prison pour
crimes contre l'humanité et corruption
pensait tenir le bon bout et mais la
tendance s'est inversée au fur et à
mesure son adversaire de la gauche
radicale pedro castillo rattrapant son
retard au fil du décompte a notamment
dans les zones rurales qui lui sont
plutôt favorables et alors que la quasi
totalité des votes ont désormais été
dépouillés le candidat au chapeau et au
crayon est finalement repassé devant
d'une courte tête
une situation ubuesque qui souligne la
division d'un peuple dans l'expectative
il faut respecter le fait que quel que
soit le candidat qui a gagné c'est parce
que la majorité des gens l'ont choisie
il faut respecter cela
le pérou est divisée ça se voit avec les
résultats mais nous devons seulement
avoir confiance en dieu car il a la
solution à tous et nous espérons que le
vainqueur quel qu'il soit ne détruira
pas le pays
le résultat n'est pas encore fixée mais
c'est la volonté du peuple et c'est
ainsi qu'il sera pris quel que soit le
gagnant
je n'ai aucune faveur ni pour l'un ni
pour l'autre le pérou qui subit des
crises politiques successives ces
dernières années espère sortir la tête
de l'eau après ces élections
rocambolesque cet état d'amérique du sud
fait face à une forte pauvreté exacerbée
par la gravité de la pandémie de covile
19 qui touche très fortement le pays
pour répondre à cette problématique ce
sont deux visions radicalement opposées
qui s'affrontent d'un côté le
libéralisme économique d'une fujimori
toujours inquiétés par la justice dans
un scandale de corruption et de
blanchiment d'argent et de l'autre un
interventionnisme de l'état prônée par
l'instituteur pedro castillo qui promeut
notamment une politique de
nationalisations
les deux candidats s'accordent en
revanche sur certains sujets sociétaux
comme celui de l'avortement auquel ils
sont tous deux opposés
et pour en parler nous sommes avec l'iss
est la pire au spécialiste du perron
professeur des universités en études
latino américaines à l'université cergy
paris bonsoir les selles qu'heroes merci
d'être avec nous des résultats donc
ultra serré actuellement on imagine
qu'il ya beaucoup de tension est ce que
vous avez des nouvelles du perron
comment les choses se trament alors oui
en effet les résultats sont extrêmement
serrés autour de 50% de
deux millions de bulletins exprimés pour
pedro castillo et 49 pour keiko fujimori
à peu près on est à 90 % des suffrages
des bulletins scruter et l'ambiance est
extrêmement il ya une forte tension on
entende attend les parisiens attendent
en fait depuis 2018 qui lie à un
président élu et démocratiquement élu
puisque on est en fait en vacance de
pouvoir depuis 7,7 cette année la fin de
2018 où le président pedro pablo
kuczynscki a dû démissionner donc depuis
on est dans une sorte book d'une
certaine stade instabilité politique et
les péruviens ou plus était vraiment
très sont déplacés aux urnes le vote est
obligatoire pour les péruviens à l'épée
reviennent donc là vraiment c'est
l'aspect native on attend les résultats
mais on est prêt de la fin du
dépouillement des scrutins est en effet
comme vous l'avez dit dans votre sujet
les votes exprimés dans les régions
surtout les régions les plus pauvres les
régions des andes et de l'amazone y ont
fortement compté dans le vote favorable
à pedro castillo qui explique justement
que c'est zones rurales et et temps pesé
en faveur de la gauche radicale quelques
bougies molière représente à la fois le
les partis traditionnels puisque le
fujimorisme est un mouvement politique
qui a été fondé par son père alberto
fujimori en 1990 et est depuis le pérou
et marquer enfin pas depuis mais en tout
cas ça s'est accentué durant ce
gouvernement par la corruption qui est
vraiment structurel de toute la sphère
politique français et reviennent pardon
que ce soit au niveau de l'exécutif
légistatives voir le judiciaire
et donc ça ce sont des votre plutôt
urbain alors que pedro castillo qui est
un professeur des écoles la professeure
des écoles d'une région andine
il est syndicaliste il représente plutôt
l'alternative populaire rurale et donc
c'est pour ça que c'est qui est vraiment
ce sont ces régions qui ont été plus
sensibles à ce discours est un discours
qui revendique justement l'inclusion de
ces zones qui ont été oubliés qui sont
marginalisés d'une certaine manière
donné d'un point de vue économique et
social par exemple on l'a vu durant la
pandémie peu d'hôpitaux pratiquement pas
de médecins qui sont concentrés dans les
villes et en particulier à lima donc
cesser cette c'est ce père ou là qui
s'est mobilisé pour justement demander
la fin de la corruption est un
investissement de l'état beaucoup plus
importante pour ces régions alors deux
candidats on le rappelle diamétralement
opposées la droite populiste d'un côté
la gauche radicale de l'autre quelle que
soit l'issue de cette élection est ce
qu'on ne risque pas d'avoir un pays
encore plus fracturées divisée oui enfin
ça c'est un fait le pérou est un pays
qui est polarisée on voit bien dans
cette dans ces élections
il est polarisée il sera très difficile
pour la personne qui occupera le qui
sera président ou présidente de
gouverner puisque que ce soit au niveau
de la l'expression des bulletins et des
votes des péruviens et paix revienne
mais aussi au parlement en congrès en le
gouvernement n'aura pas une majorité
donc il y aura pas même pas cette lune
de miel qui existent en général durant
un an pour lui
pour la nouvelle présidence là il faudra
vraiment composé faire des alliances
politiques ne sera pas du tout facile
c'est vraiment pas un cadeau pour la
personne qui arrivera au pouvoir le 28
juillet puisque ces démentis juillet le
jour de l'investiture au pérou et donc
il faudra vraiment faire organiser un
gouvernement qui qui combat qui agissent
très rapidement plus particulièrement je
pense pour ces millions de personnes qui
sont dans la pauvreté le perron compte
quand même ma femme durant cette année
de pandémie eh bien on a vu le nombre de
pauvres vraiment augmenté on est à trois
millions de personnes sur un pays qui
compte 30 millions dont vous voyez c'est
quand même extrêmement important le pays
le plus touché des l'amérique latine par
le col et 19 vraiment on a tout un
chantier social important a pour la
nouvelle présidence qui arrivera en
juillet nature et enfin en tout cas à
rajouter des tensions et des crispations
le clan de keiko fujimori crient à la
fraude 1 depuis que son adversaire donc
on en parlait de la gauche est passé
devant elle a dénoncé des irrégularités
et une volonté de saboter la volonté du
peuple les officiels indiquent n'avoir
relevé aucun incident majeur
on imagine que c'est quand même le
poison qui est distillée
même si on sait pas qui croire dans
cette affaire oui bon ça je pense que
c'est ce sont des méthodes politicienne
qui sont très doux de déjà vu et connu
il faut savoir que quelqu'un fût immolé
quand même content avec toute la l'appui
des médias
il ya c'était d'un parti le fujimorisme
comme je vous le disais existe depuis
des décennies des décennies
il ya eu toute la bourgeoisie péruvienne
les les classes supérieures dont
péruvienne qui sont qui ont qui useront
lui ont donné leur appui
donc vraiment elle compte avec beaucoup
de moyens donc là c'est une façon de
peser un peu de mettre un peu la
pression sur certains emprunts de
l'organisation qui dépouillent de
dépouillement là on paie qui dépouillent
les bulletins au pérou et pour mot sur
deuxième et dans cette stratégie je
dirais plutôt politicienne parce qu'au
début lorsque les
le dépouillement était favorable on
parlait pas du tout de de fraudes ni au
contraire ou respectait le travail de
cette de cet organisme c'était
institutions je pense que là c'est parce
que les fujimoristes on sentent le vent
tourner et là la différence je pense que
ça ne sera pas elle sera pas possible de
rattraper au mont reste quand même sur
dix victoires prend très probable deux
points de location
merci beaucoup au lycée la pierre aux
spécialistes du perron professeur des
universités en études latino américaines
à l'université cergy paris la fin d'une
ère on y serait la knesset organisera
dimanche un vote de confiance au nouveau
gouvernement dernière étape avant la
mise en place au pouvoir de la coalition
formée par le centriste yaïr lapid et
l'ultra nationaliste naftali bennett un
exécutif hétéroclite qui devrait mettre
un terme à douze années de pouvoir
ininterrompu de bahia mines étaient nés
ou est détaillé avec françois-xavier
d'anvers le suspense n'a donc pas duré
très longtemps
après avoir annoncé que le vote au
nouveau gouvernement israélien aurait
lieu d'ici au 14 juin
le président du parlement a tranché la
consultation se tiendra dimanche
prochain
d'ici là benyamin nétanyahou espère
encore ralliés in extremis des députés à
sa cause
mais pour yaïr lapid la coalition qui
l'a mise en place sera bel et bien
investi avec tous les chefs des partis
du changement et j'ai vu leur
détermination
ce gouvernement sera bien formés et ce
sera un gouvernement de qualité et
durable parce qu'il se fonde sur des
éléments positifs la confiance qui la
décence et la bonne volonté pour
reverser benyamin nétanyahou le
centriste yaïr lapid est parvenu à
former une large coalition comprenant le
parti de droite radicale de naftali
bennet ainsi que six autres formations
dont un parti arabes israéliens alors
qu'il fait tout pour s'accrocher au
pouvoir l'actuel premier ministre
istres est accusé par ses adversaires
d'inciter à la violence des accusations
dont il se défend la liberté
d'expression n'a rien à voir avec
l'incitation à la violence
on ne peut pas dire que quand la
critique vient de droite c'est de
l'incitation à la violence et que quand
elle vient de gauche c'est une
utilisation justifier de la liberté
d'expression on essaie ainsi de
présenter la droite comme quelque chose
de violent et de dangereux pour la
démocratie
des invectives par médias interposés qui
inquiète jusqu'aux services de sécurité
ce samedi le chef du shin bet le
renseignement intérieur israélien a mis
en garde contre la surenchère des
discours incitant à la haine tout en
appelant les différents partis à mettre
un terme à l' escalade verbale après
douze années consécutives au pouvoir
benyamin netanyahou semble donc plus que
jamais prêt de la sortie
julian assange est loin d'une libération
en quelques jours après un rassemblement
autour de la faim du journaliste pour
demander sa libération immédiate
le rapporteur spécial de l'onu a donné
son avis sur la question si son état de
santé était décrit comme critique
il est très improbable de le voir
libérés à cause des fonds trop
importants investis par plusieurs pays
il faut être clair concernant les états
principalement impliquée dans cette
persécution les etats-unis le
royaume-uni la suède est malheureusement
l'équateur après le changement de
gouvernement en 2017 ont dépensé des
millions et déployé des efforts
considérables pour persécuter julian
assange et le faire taire ils ne sont
pas prêts de le libérer
ni lui permettre de retrouver sa
profession initial après toutes ces
années de brimades
je présume qu'ils essaieront de le
garder emprisonné aussi longtemps que
possible les britanniques
même s'ils ont envie de l'extrader
peuvent craindre que julian assange est
c'est de faire appel à la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme parce
qu'alors il sera très difficile
d'obtenir son extradition vers les
etats-unis
c'est pourquoi il essaie de le maintenir
aussi longtemps que possible
dans un purgatoire sans cesse renouvelée
par des procédures judiciaire
interminable avec nous dans quelques
instants nous parlerons de l'agression
des mesnel l'écran lors d'un déplacement
dans la drôme le président qui parle
d'un incident et d'un fait isolé et puis
nous évoquons la situation sanitaire en
france la veille d'une nouvelle étape de
déconfinement pour vos feux décalé à 23h
télétravail est sous pli ou bien encore
en lançant mais pas sanitaires
m
[Musique]
la repentance est un sentiment aux
conséquences extrêmement graves pour
l'avenir
cette pratique obsessionnel s'impose
dans l'esprit de nos dirigeants comme la
condition incontournable d'une
gouvernance responsable moderne plutôt
que de se repentir
on ferait mieux de faire référence à un
passé dont on peut être fier
nous trouvons un autre exemple des
limites de cette transparence dans
l'utilisation de la raison d'état pour
cacher la vérité sous la pression
médiatique et la raison d'état on
pratique une sélection du bien et du mal
à géométrie variable
il faut sauver la liberté d'expression
qui est prise en otage dans une
inversion entre le juste et le client
[Musique]
pour beaucoup le foot a été synonyme
d'évasion durant cette période de la
pandémie
quel est le rôle justement du football
dans notre société en temps de crise
je pense que ça a été bien de continuer
le football pour s'évader un peu aussi
haut niveau au niveau mental on est tous
conscients que le football ligny tout ce
qui est au niveau social surtout au
niveau culture et quel regard
portez-vous sur toutes ces années à
monaco à la juventus en équipe de france
le football le football c'est ma vie et
le football m'a beaucoup donné en temps
dans tous les contextes et quand on a la
chance de revenir en étant ambassadeur
voir les gens
vous reconnaître les choses qu'on a fait
et non surtout au niveau du beau
football et ça c'est touchant
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
la raison pour laquelle les gens qui
font appel à moi s'engage dans un combat
c'est parce que il ya de l'autre côté
une classe ultra privilégiés qui est
prête à sacrifier l'être humain en
réalité pour accroître encore davantage
ses richesses
les chiffres qui sont avancés qui sont
montrés aux salariés et à leurs
représentants sont des chiffres en
décalage parfois vertigineux avec les
chiffres que l'on trouve dans la
comptabilité officielle notre travail
c'est justement de dissiper cet écran de
fumée de gratter le maquillage et de
faire émerger la réalité des profits
gigantesques que réalise ces firmes
mais comment peuvent ils mentir comme
des arracheurs de dents à ce point
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur arte
france pour un nouveau numéro du débrief
du doc on semble on va s'intéresser 7
faux documentaire intitulé mig sukhoï
les secrets des avions de combat russes
et pour en parler je ne suis pas seule
elle nous sommes avec le général patrick
charest bonjour monsieur charest ou
plutôt mon général d'ailleurs comment
dois je vous appelez oui vous pouvez
m'appeler général patrick charix et bien
écoutez mon général avant de rentrer
dans le vif du sujet je voulais tout
simplement vous présentez un aux
téléspectateurs puisque vous aviez une
grande carrière militaire vous êtes
ancien pilote de chasse vous avez
commandé la base aérienne de djibouti
est tenu des postes en état major au
commandement de la défense aérienne et
dans les forces aériennes
j'ai dit vous avez été général de corps
aérien vous avez surtout tenu le poste
de commandant des forces aériennes
stratégiques
on charge la composante aérienne air de
la dissuasion nucléaire
j'aimerais qu'on s'intéresse aux pilotes
dans ce documentaire on entend un pilote
russe parler de de son expérience de sa
passion je vous propose de regarder un
extrait ensemble et puis on débrief
juste après j'ai grandi à côté de la
base aérienne
tous les vols qui ont lieu depuis le
centre aérien de tête ce que se sont dit
oui depuis mon enfance je rêvais de
devenir pilote et va être violent de
chasse pour effectuer les manoeuvres que
seuls les avions de chasse avec mon rêve
s'est réalisé
je suis atteint mi 29 je crois que cet
appareil est parmi les meilleurs au
monde
il offre de nombreuses possibilités aux
pilotes est devenu pilote de cet
appareil
je suis absolument ravi alors vous
l'avez entendu un bon général dans cet
extrait on entend le pilote parler de sa
passion de son rêve de devenir pilote
vous êtes d'accord avec ce qu'il dit
c'est une véritable vocation que de
devenir pilote
je comprends tout à fait ce pilote de
chasse d'ailleurs pour l'avoir aussi
vécu quand vous êtes dans
l'environnement d'une base aérienne
quand vous entendez ces avions qui
décollent avec la postcombustion qui
passe en très basse altitude
vous les regardez en disant c'est le
rêve d'icare ccvo laisse et c'est
s'affranchir de cette troisième
dimension est là pour le coup vous rêvez
et donc
ce métier quand même pas facile il faut
l'avouer avec pas mal de difficultés à
la fois physique pression et puis
surtout la technologie
il faut savoir combattre tout ça et ça
vous le faites à travers votre foi votre
votre vocation est ce qui vous fait
tirer vers le haut et accepté entre 10
mai entre guillemets ses difficultés du
moment
alors c'est un métier qui a aussi était
sublimée au cinéma on pense au film top
gun mais forcément la réalité est bien
est bien différente on apprend dans le
documentaire que l'on a que l'on a vu
qu' il faut quatre ans de services pour
maîtriser à peu près toutes les
émissions et devenir opérationnels
devenir pilote vous l'avez dit c'est un
métier à très difficile quelles sont les
qualités selon vous pour pour devenir un
bon pilote et bien pour être un bon
pilote déjà il va falloir passer deux
tests qui sont fondamentaux pour pouvoir
de c'est à dire le test médical
r là vous pouvez rien si vous êtes
daltoniens si votre colonne vertébrale
et pas droite pour le siège éjectable
vous serez naturellement éliminé et
saint vous n'y pouvez rien c c'est
physique ces dîners et puis ensuite il
va falloir passer ces tests
psychotechniques qui montrent que dans
la troisième dimension
vous réagissez vous n'êtes pas malade et
vous êtes capable de prendre un peu tout
ce qui touche aux côtés physiologique et
un peu médical pour être un bon pilote
d'abord la condition physique c'est pour
ça veut dire qu'on fait beaucoup de
sport fait beaucoup de 2,2 de course à
pied pour le coeur pour pouvoir soutenir
ces facteurs de charge est aussi
aujourd'hui avec ses avions électriques
on prend quand même d'une objets coin
donc on pèse 9 fois son corps vous aimez
divine et le sang qui quitte le cerveau
et donc il faut il faut résister ensuite
il faut avoir un peu cette vision du
court terme c'est à dire je réagis en
fonction de ce qui se passe autour de
moi j'ai cette vision dans la 3d trois
dimensions
je sais où vient la menace je sais je la
vois et donc pour ça j'ai vous
évidemment besoin d'une bonne vision et
à la fois aujourd'hui je suis capable
et tout mais capteurs dans mon avion
c'est parce que vous avez fait une
différence d'entrée par exemple à 1029
qu'on aperçoit un peu et aujourd'hui un
rafale l'intérieur de l'avion est
complètement différent on parlait
justement ensemble de ces différences
entre entre les appareils parmi les
avions de combat qui existe aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il y en aurait un plus
performant qu'un autre et où un homme
qui vous impressionne plus
particulièrement encore une fois la
grande difficulté parce que c'est que
les russes ne communique pas sur leurs
avions sur leurs capacités mais on sait
qu'aujourd'hui le sukhoï 57 et le futur
qui arrive le futur 1041 qui arrivent
sont les deux futurs avions de cinquième
génération et c'est d'ailleurs il
l'appelle comme cela et donc on est et
le peu de choses près équivalent au f-35
au f-22 et le rafale et de quatrième
génération plus là on parle de cinquième
génération
on parle beaucoup donc du coup le
système de systèmes d'intégration
d'intelligence artificielle
moyennant quoi si on veut regarder un
peu concrètement sur le terrain
le rafale a fait vraiment ses preuves
dans tous les derniers théâtres
d'opération mais pour vous dire que les
avions qui peuvent qu'impressionner
aujourd'hui sont effectivement peut-être
ses avions russes si on les connaissait
un peu mieux je note au passage que les
chinois sont aussi en train de après à
force de regarder de copier aussi sont
aussi en train de créer des avions qui
sont de très bonnes technologies
la problème c'est comment on n'a pas
d'informations on peut pas comparer
vraiment mais le f-35 évidemment du côté
occidental fait fait un peu rêver et le
futur skaff européen d'assaut vous savez
que les allemands et aux airbus on
construit quelque chose pour 2035 2040
qui semble être extraordinaire est à la
hauteur voire légèrement supérieurs à
ceux là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième émission tout de suite
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mardi 8 juin
emmanuel macron dénonce des faits zidrou
isolé d'individus ultra violent et
rappelle la nécessité de respecter les
fonctions de la république réélection
quelques heures après avoir été giflé
par un homme lors d'un déplacement dans
la drôme
deux hommes ont été interpellés
condamnation unanime de la classe
politique
la troisième étape du déconfinement est
pour demain avec le couvre-feu repoussé
à 23 heures les bars et restaurants qui
pourront à nouveau servir leurs clients
à l'intérieur et ouverture également des
piscines vaisselle de sport en
respectant une jour de 50%
mais pour jean françois delfraissy
président du conseil scientifique il
faut rester prudent une question bague
est à craindre à la rentrée du côté du
monde de la nuit une lueur emmanuel mec
qu'on leur a donné rendez vous le 21
juin
au brésil les voyants sanitaires sont au
rouge certains épidémiologistes ken une
troisième bague encore plus meurtrière
que les deux premières
le pays qui devrait atteindre d'ici la
fin du mois ce triste record avec cinq
cent mille morts les mesures de
restriction resta sont pliés la campagne
de vaccination patine seulement 10 8% de
la population a été immunisée avec deux
doses
[Musique]
des images pour le moment inattendu en
déplacement à tain l'hermitage dans la
drôme emmanuel macron a reçu une gifle
de la part d'un homme lors d'un bain de
foule
la classe politiques de tous bords a
immédiatement réagi apporté son soutien
au chef de l'état pour plus de
précisions on retrouve tout de suite
monnaie hamoudi l'or en direct de
l'elysée bonsoir monheim et des
maquereaux qui a donc réagi ce soir
après avoir été agressé lors de ce bal
food
oui emmanuel macron a préféré tempérer
et parler de faits isolés il faut
relativiser tout va bien at-il dit
écoutez le le peuple français est un
peuple républicain
l'écrasante majorité des français est
intéressé par les problèmes de fond sur
le principe je serai intraitable mais ne
laissons pas des faits isolés des
individus ultra violent comme il y en a
toujours quelques-uns dans les
manifestations aussi prendre possession
du débat public il ne le mérite pas pour
le moment deux individus ont été placés
en garde à vue
juste après l agression à l'assemblée
jean castex le premier ministre on a
appelé à un sursaut républicain écoutez
le à travers le chef de l'état c'est
tout simplement la démocratie qu'est
viser la démocratie
la démocratie mesdames et messieurs les
députés la démocratie et vous en est
l'illustration c'est le sait le débat
c'est le dialogue c'est la confrontation
d'idées c'est l'expression de désaccord
légitime
bien entendu mais ça ne peut en aucun
cas être la violence l'agression verbale
et encore moins l'agression physique
j'en appelle à un sursaut républicain
nous sommes tous concernés
il en va des fondements de notre
démocratie je vous remercie et vous
l'imaginez les réactions politiques sont
unanimes tous condamnent fermement cette
agression je vous propose d'écouter les
réactions de certaines personnalités
politiques qui ont commenté écoutez les
cette fois-ci vous commencez à
comprendre que les violents passe à
l'acte je suis solidaire du président si
le débat démocratique peut être âpre il
ne saurait en aucun cas tolérer la
violence physique
je condamne fermement l'agression
physique intolérable qui a visé le
président de la république
je condamne avec la plus grande fermeté
le geste inacceptable dont a été victime
emmanuel macron aucun des accords
politiques ne justifiera jamais la
violence le respect des institutions de
la république et de ses représentants
est en principe cardinal de notre vie
démocratique
exactement ce qu'est papa si tôt ça y
est vous la prenez au sérieux la
violence d'extrême droite maintenant
solidaire du président quelle a été la
réaction de l'entourage
emmanuel macron
je viens l'entourage qui prouve dans la
république a tenté de minimiser l'acte
et parle plutôt de tentatives de givre
d'ailleurs le président de la république
a continué sa journée comme si rien ne
s'était passé
mais ce n'est pas le premier président à
avoir été pris pour cible souvenez-vous
en 2011 nicolas sarkozy avait été
violemment tiré par le col à brax en
tout cas à cette agression et bien elle
met en exergue la violence dénoncé
depuis plusieurs jours par certains
politiques français c'est un signe
également avec la crise sociale et
sociétale est encore exacerbée dans
notre pays à quelques mois de la
campagne présidentielle
merci mon âme ou deux alors en direct de
l'elysée est avec nous pour en parler
virginie martin politologue professeur
halak edge business school bonsoir
virginie martin merci d'être avec nous
que vous évoque cette image d'un
président de la république gifler en
pleine rue d'abord quelque chose ou si
enfin il faut remettre les choses dans
leur contexte ont fait vous savez c'est
quand même pas la première fois que tout
ça arrive la journaliste qui ont direct
de l'elysée le disais il ya eu aussi des
choses bien plus graves pour le pacéen
il y a eu l'attentât du petit clamart à
l'encontre du général de gaulle il y a
eu aussi la tentative d'attentât un 14
juillet 2002 à l'égard de jacques chirac
vous voyez là on parle plutôt des plus
hauts dans le registre je veux pas dire
un peu minimale mais voilà il faut quand
même relativiser raison garder ce que
fait d'ailleurs emmanuel macron puis
après aussi on peut penser à aux oeufs
au catch up à la farine aux tartes que
les sarkozy gspr hollande ont pu
recevoir par le passé aussi ou manuel
valls qui avait aussi eu un petit coup
physique comme cela
donc la politique quand elle dit en
contact et de toute façon souvent fait
de violence ça veut dire quoi
vous la banaliser cette
violences en tout cas vous la
relativiser comme le fait d'ailleurs ce
soir emmanuel macron qui parle de faits
isolés d'un individu ultraviolents vous
êtes sur la même ligne c'est à dire que
je ne veux pas la banaliser
on ne peut pas banaliser de toute façon
est un acte de violence qu'ils soient
réels d'ailleurs que l'avion soit réel
ou qu'elles soient symboliques ou
qu'elle soit verbale ou que c'est ça
c'est de toute façon très grave et c'est
un préambule et c'est normal mais
maintenant aussi il y a une façon de
dire c'est un fait isolé mais qui est en
même temps dans un contexte bien entendu
un contexte de tension de tension
politique de tension économique de
tensions sociales
donc quelque part bien sûr tout d'un
coup le président la république à la fin
par sa fonction mais emmanuel macron
l'hymen cristallise de toute façon ses
frustrations ses colères ses wee cc
tension et ses inquiétudes aussi
notamment post confinement ça c'est une
évidence mais ya deux choses en fait
emmanuel macron et deux personnes en
même temps si je puis dire il est à la
fois le symbole de la république il est
à la fois l'homme politique et magali
napperons lui même comment expliquer en
tout cas cette gifle une trop grande
proximité ou la détermination d'un
évident yeux comme d'un ami divy dieu
comme l'a dit le chef de l'état il ne
faudrait pas que le président s'offre à
des bains de foule comme ça on sait très
bien c'est une grande tradition
française que d'abord c'est dingue foule
donc on ne pourra pas de toute façon
changer cela d'ailleurs emmanuel macron
tout de suite retourne au contact retour
dans la foule
d'ailleurs même on peut même penser qui
derrière il capitalise cet événement
pourront faire après de la communication
politique
finalement à son bénéfice ça c'est
évident mais après on n'est pas dans une
tradition russe ou américaine où les
présidents sont évidemment à nash est
derrière comme ça des voitures
absolument délirante des services de
sécurité délirant et notamment aux états
unis
il ya quelque chose d'important qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que le président
ait éventuellement la présidence ne de
toute façon ne s'appartiennent pas ça
c'est important
ils appartiennent à la nation américaine
en france c'est pas pareil
le président peut être un jour une
présidente de toute façon sa partie en
lumens effet un peu comme il l'entend ça
c'est une grande différence aussi donc
le contact le bain de foule est une
tradition à la française rappelons-nous
aussi des salons de l'agriculture de
jacques chirac jacques chirac et
pourtant on est loin des styles à
virginie martin on avait un jacques
chirac très proche des gens on se
souvient de cette mémorable
effectivement au salon de l'agriculture
alors que on reproche en tout cas les
détracteurs du président de la
république les reproches une forme
d'arrogance s est ce qui cristallise la
colère de certains ont peut-être bien
sûr bien sûr c'est à dire que emmanuel
macron à cultiver aussi de manière un
peu simultanée au début de son
quinquennat
vraiment une très grande verticalité on
se rappelle ils sont tous nommés jupiter
il a fait une intronisation avec cette
pyramide du louvre très solennelle on
avait retrouvé quelques ceux de three
monarchique très verticale très puissant
voire un peu narcissique qui gênaient
aussi et tout de suite après quelques
temps après il a aussi changé de braquet
et puis aujourd'hui la semaine dernière
on le voit joue en parlant extrêmement
mal sur les réseaux sociaux avec mc fly
et carlito d'aucuns peuvent dire qu'il a
désacralisé aussi la fonction tout en
faisant une verticalité et qu'elle un
président relativement isolé ou ressenti
comme tel c'est toute l'ambiguïté aussi
peut-être du personnage une ultra
verticalisation peut-être bien trop
appuyé mais peut-être aussi une trop
grande horizontalité peut être elle
aussi trop appuyé est on obligé d'aller
jusque à parler de drogue sur les
réseaux sociaux avec mc fly et carlito
la question peut se poser sur la
sacralité de la fonction alors tant de
conséquences pour cent en images quelles
conséquences pour pour son image c'est
une conséquence je pense finalement
plutôt bénéfique parce qu'il ya deux
choses à voir d'abord il ya l'événement
bon très bien cette tentative de j et
puis après il ya l'instrumentalisation
qui en tient qu en effet ça c'est très
important c'est peut-être le discours
sur l'événement qui est plus important
étudier et là on voit bien que chaque
camp de gauche comme de droite emmanuel
macron inclus finalement instrumentalise
l'événement alors la droite voire la
droite dure radical dit bien sûr que
cris à la violence de la société
cria à une trop grande finalement
démocratisation il faut qu'on revienne à
quelque chose de beaucoup plus dure
beaucoup plus sérieux que la justice
soit faite et cetera et puis la gauche
elle demande aussi justice et notamment
l'extrême gauche avec cette cet épisode
quand même et seul cette vidéo de papa
sitôt d'une violence inouïe inouïe qui
appelle vraiment au meurtre qui dit
comment à la limite assassiné des gens
de gauche d'extrême gauche de la france
a soumises et là aussi bien sur cette
gauche-là réclame qu'il n'y ait pas deux
poids deux mesures et ça c'est aussi
quelque chose d'important
et puis emmanuel macron qui dit tout de
suite je suis un peu tombé de cheval et
je remonte tout de suite en scène et
vous avez vu il ya eu des images
officielles qui ont été diffusées et là
tout d'un coup on entend au contraire un
président adoubé acclamé qui prend les
numéros de téléphone personnels de
chacun qui a ses problèmes et ses acquis
mais des petites langue dans sa poche
qui dit regardez c'est ma brigitte et là
c'est la séquence émotion la séquence
intimité la séquence vraiment de là
cette mise en scène de la vie politique
contemporaine avec des séquences émotion
très forte trop fortes pourront dire
certains aussi merci à virginie martin
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur arte france
les activités de lafarge en série passée
au crible par la justice française le
groupe cimentier est accusé d'avoir
financé des groupes armés en syrie en
2013 et 2014 après l'annulation en appel
de sa mise en examen pour complicité de
crime contre l'humanité
l' affaire a été examinée aujourd'hui
par la cour de cassation
les précisions d'estelle farges la cour
de cassation se prononcera le 15 juillet
prochain sur l'annulation de la mise en
examen du cimentier lafarge pour
complicité de crimes contre l'humanité
concernant l ses activités en syrie
jusqu'en 2014 cette audience aujourd'hui
elle fait suite au pourvoi en cassation
de deux ong l'association els sherpa et
le centre européen pour les droits
constitutionnels et les droits de
l'homme ces deux organisations
elle souhaite pouvoir se constituer
partie civile dans le dossier
justement sur ce dossier lafarge est
soupçonné d'avoir versé via sa filiale
lcs lafarge com and syria près de 13
millions d'euros à des groupes
jihadistes dont l'état islamique en 2013
et en 2014 dans le but de maintenir son
activité en syrie en 2018 c'est lafarge
avait donc été mise en examen en tant
que personne morale pour complicité de
crime contre l'humanité
elle saisit par lafarge la cour d'appel
de paris avait invalidé cette mise en
examen en novembre 2019 la cour de
cassation va donc examiner à la faire
sur la forme et juger de la pertinence
de cette qualification pour rappel le
cimentier reste mis en examen pour trois
chefs d'accusation financement d'une
entreprise terroriste violation d'un
embargo et enfin la mise en danger de la
vie
d'anciens salariés de son usine située
dans le nord de la syrie c'est important
puisque ce sont elles des qualifications
- lourdes le financement d'une
entreprise terroriste suppose d'avoir
donné de l'argent d'avoir financé des
actes terroristes mais son mobile un
particulier
de l'autre côté la complicité de crimes
contre l'humanité implique non seulement
la connaissance du projet criminel mais
aussi l adhésion à celui ci elle c'est
donc sur cette nuance que vont se
pencher les magistrats de la cour de la
cour de cassation en france j - avant la
deuxième étape du plan de déconfinement
dès demain vous pourrez poursuivre votre
soirée à l'extérieur jusqu'à 23 heures
retrouvez votre salle de sport ou encore
celle de vos restaurants préférés des
assouplissements qui ont lieu alors que
les indicateurs sont au beau fixe
près de 2400 personnes en réanimation
soit une baisse significative de 15 % en
sept jours
mais les français sont appelés à ne pas
baisser la garde cet été les
explications de scarlett pain en
déplacement dans la drôme
emmanuel macron s'est montré optimiste
par rapport aux plans de déconfinement
mais il a aussi appelé les français à la
prudence
c'est une étape importante il faut se
donner ces trois semaines parce que ce
sont les trois semaines qui vont nous
permettre de voir si des risques
réapparaissent jusqu'à présent
l'évolution de la situation sanitaire a
permis au gouvernement de dérouler son
plan comme prévu et le chef de l'état
invite même de nouveaux acteurs à y
prendre part
pour les discothèques rendez vous le 21
juin autre surprise qui pourrait réjouir
les français la fin du port du masque en
extérieur après le 30 juin les
indicateurs épidémiques sont à ce stade
meilleur que les prévisions du conseil
scientifique mais son président prédit
un scénario comme celui vécu par le
royaume uni qui lui fait redouter un
rebond épidémique inéluctable je crains
que nous nous trouvions pendant l'été ou
à la rentrée de septembre avec nous
aussi un switch avec la disparition du
variant anglais pour aller vers le
variant indien après un été qui va
globalement bien se passer si on ne fait
pas trop de bêtises il y aura une
reprise de l'épidémie on peut l'appeler
quatrième vague mais elle sera très
différente des premières vagues parce
qu'on aura la vaccination d'après santé
publique france la souche classique du
virus ne compte plus que pour 5% tandis
que le vary anglais circulent
à plus de 70% selon l' oms les vaccins
serait pour le moment efficace contre
les mutations du virus
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
françois blanchecotte président du
syndicat des biologistes bonsoir franz
koch merci d'être avec nous donc demain
nouvelle étape
les bons chiffres qui appuient cette
décision cet allègement pour vous il est
légitime vous vous y allez le coeur
léger
il est légitime oui parce que nous avons
effectivement des clignotants qui sont
au vert comme il a été dit mais avec ce
que comme l'a dit jean françois
delfraissy une surveillance intense de
tous les cas positifs sur le territoire
qui va être conduite à partir du 14 juin
sous forme de dépistage et de séquençage
de toutes les souches que nous allons
pouvoir trouver en france
alors effectivement vous parler entre
autres un de ce variant delta qui semble
tout de même inquiété c'est un peu
aujourd'hui la seule ombre au tableau
est ce qui est peu prendre à plus ou
moins long terme le dessus en france
aussi bien sûr il ya une compétition
entre les gens qui sont vaccinées
protéger et puis les gens qui ne le sont
pas dans lequel le virus évidemment peut
rendre un cluster positif un certain
nombre de gens d'où l'exploration
absolue de tous les gens qui ouvrent il
ya eu une naissance d'un nouveau variant
de nouvelles mutations et donc de la
surveillance à absolu de tous ces
personnes plus d'une centaine de quatre
variants ont été détectés
par séquençage c'est bien cela ça veut
dire qu'on est en dessous de la réalité
aujourd'hui
écoutez on le saura un petit peu plus
pour l'instant nous avons un criblage
qui est fait en france autour de trois
mutations que nos recherches qui était
présente à la fois sur le vario anglais
sur le variant sud africains brésiliens
indiens et c'est autour de ces trois
mutations cible si vous voulez que l'on
va identifier les souches
il convainc systématiquement les passer
au peigne fin pour voir s'ils
contiennent ou non de notre mutation qui
peuvent comme vous l'avez dit avoir une
dangerosité entre en termes de
contamination et en termes aussi de
résistance à la vaccination
c'est vrai que jean françois delfraissy
du conseil scientifique nous on dit
attention à la reprise de l'épidémie à
l'automne ce que vous nous dites la
mutation est ce qu'elle serait la cause
justement de cette potentielle quatrième
vague qu'on espère évidemment pas bien
effectivement oui parce que si vous avez
un cerveau ou d'un grand nombre de
personnes rassemblées et qui n'ont pas
été vaccinés c'est important
elles peuvent contaminer à ce moment-là
devenir un cluster se disséminer et donc
on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui on
l'avait prévu d'ailleurs que le variant
anglais prendrait le dessus sur le
vaillant traditionnels que nous avons
est la dernière maintenant c'est la
question de savoir si d'autres variantes
peuvent se substituer aux parieurs
anglais est donc évidemment contaminer
d'autres personnes c'est c'est cette
course là
ces précautions qu'il faut garder même
s'il ya effectivement cette libération
d'une certaine manière qui est cette
protection qu'il faut garder quand on
est dans un endroit confiné cesser ces
mesures là qui vont voir si on va être
efficace ou pas cet été des variants qui
essaient bien de le rappeler sont sont
toujours à priori
poreuse aux vaccins oui tout à fait pour
l'instant nous avons d'après l'om est
après tout les études que nous avons
nous avons une de bons résultats dans
tous les cas de vaccination
donc c'est ça qui va être très important
on va pouvoir surveiller aussi les gens
par leur passeport évidemment leur
passante et ce qui permettra de mesurer
aussi tous les gens vaccinés et de
mesurer plus tard éventuellement les
anticorps qu'ils auront contre le virus
clairement aujourd'hui l'europe et eto'o
vers dans sa globalité alors que des
pays sans à nouveau dans les crises
grâce à quoi on peut parler de la
vaccination uniquement où il ya d'autres
raisons
non on parle aussi de la politique de
l'état qui a fait qu'à un moment donné
il a été nécessaire de vacciner de
protéger nos concitoyens en disant il
faut évidemment vous met 7 jours 10
jours chez vous il faut aussi cette
politique d'identifier toutes les
personnes que vous avez pu être en
contact dans toute cette politique là
aujourd'hui paye un peu et on en
recueille les fruits maintenant comme
l'année dernière ça va être l'été qui va
être une la clé de notre réussite ou pas
si nous continuons à vacciner très
fortement cet été que nous continuons à
nous protéger dans les lieux clos et que
nous essayons de t'avoir respect un peu
des gestes barrières les uns vis-à-vis
des autres on aurait une chance que au
mois de septembre octobre quand les le
temps va se changer on puisse éviter
cette quatrième vague
un mot également sur cette annonce des
manuels macro destination des
discothèques rendez vous le 21 juin
ça inquiète le biologiste que vous êtes
c'est peut-être le dernier endroit
effectivement à haut risque certainement
oui
quoique dans les discothèques il y a
puisque j'en ai j'en ai quelques membres
de mason qui en sont c'est un endroit
qui peut être facilement arriver en tout
cas une aspiration de l'air très forte
qui peut être déclenché donc il ya deux
possibilités mais c'est vrai que on
attend les résultats de de tous les
concerts qui vont être mené avec 1000
personnes de voir un peu quel est l'état
de dissémination parmi des gens qui sont
ensemble
donc tous et tous ces éléments là vont
permettre de prendre certainement une
décision par le chef de l'état dans une
certaine mesure avec certainement des
jauges avec certainement des précautions
mais certainement que des discothèques
qui sont dehors pour être plus
facilement accessible qu'en sous sol
merci beaucoup françois blanchecotte
président du syndicat des biologistes
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france ce soir le dernier budget de la
sécurité sociale prévoyaient une
contribution exceptionnelle d'un
milliard et demi d'euros sur deux ans
pour les organismes complémentaires en
compensation les économies réalisées
pendant l'épidémie
mais le gouvernement veut désormais
augmenter la taxe co vite sur les
complémentaires santé ont fait le point
en images
[Musique]
où
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur la situation
sanitaire au brésil les voyants sont au
rouge et certains épidémiologistes
craignent même une troisième vague
encore plus meurtrière les deux
précédentes
et puis direction et il y toujours
aucune solution à la crise
constitutionnelle que traverse le pays
depuis des mois le référendum prévu le
27 juin est reportée sine die
[Musique]
le ms a exhorté certains pays africains
à ne pas détruire les vaccins anti covit
péri mais il faut craindre une
vaccination low cost en afrique lors une
vaccination à l'est une vaccination
savez la vaccination ce n'est pas elle
n'a pas commencé avec la guitare
le problème ça reste quand même
l'approvisionnement reste que c'est la
faute des pays les plus riches qui
accapare justement les productions de
l'accent où est le mécanisme de la
vaccination vous savez ça a soulevé
beaucoup d'enjeux sur la question de la
solidarité si on peut en faire plus en
terme de solidarité de partage
c'est quelque chose d'absolument
important on sait que le nigeria affirme
qu'il élabore son propre vaccin contre
le coc u19 pour en finir avec justement
la dépendance vis-à-vis des laboratoires
étrangers
que ce soit le sénégal le nigeria
l'afrique du sud beaucoup de pays ont
cette admission l'avoir amené l'agenda
de la santé publique au top des
priorités c'est quelque chose que nous
saluons énormément au niveau de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
et puis
deux termes banlieue voir le terme cité
c'est forcément péjoratif c'est vrai que
les médias ont un regard on va dire
assez particulier des banlieues et qui
dérange aujourd'hui et on donne cette
impression de la banlieue ça serait une
vraie cas des jeunes violents contre une
police qui serait son travail c'est plus
compliqué que ça on est français on est
fiers de vivre dans ces quartiers même
s'il ya des difficultés est la moindre
des choses c'est d'inscrire aussi notre
empreinte canton quand on participe à la
vie de la société et malheureusement il
n'y a pas cette reconnaissance
aujourd'hui je pense que le changement
viendra d'abord à travers cette
conscientisation des citoyens des
quartiers populaires on parle également
des deux zones de reconquête
républicaine
au final derrière ces mots qu'est ce qui
casse qui se cachent et politique fort
pour les gens mais sans les gens c'est à
dire qui donne cette impression de faire
de vouloir changer les choses mais
concrètement politiquement ils ne le
font pas
le théâtre du châtel c'est par théâtre
comme les autres c'est un théâtre qui
est très diversifiée dans un
programmation de la culture est une
activité absolument essentiel de notre
société de sa cohésion de sa cohérence
c'est aussi le rôle du châtelet de
pouvoir mettre en contact des très
belles productions avec le public
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans un théâtre en
plein confinement on a essayé de
réinventer notre métier et en
particulier on a fait beaucoup de
travail avec la télévision on a permis
de capter un certain nombre de
spectacles pour la télévision ce qui est
une autre manière de pouvoir créer la
relation avec le public je suis sûr
qu'il y aura une grande volonté du
public de revenir dans les théâtres
[Musique]
pour beaucoup le foot a été synonyme
d'évasion durant cette période de la
pandémie
quel est le rôle justement du football
dans notre société en temps de crise
je pense que ça a été bien de continuer
le football pour s'évader un peu aussi
haut niveau au niveau mental
on est tous conscients que le football
ligny tout ce qui est au niveau social
surtout au niveau culture et quel regard
portez-vous sur toutes ces années à
monaco à la juventus en équipe de france
le football le football c'est ma vie et
le football m'a beaucoup donné en trente
ans tous les contextes et quand on a la
chance de revenir en étant ambassadeur
voir les gens
nous reconnaître les choses qu'on a fait
et non surtout au niveau du beau
football et ça c'est tout champions
m
quand même
patin jeu donnant pas seulement le
cinéma
ils sont le cinéma
[Musique]
charles pathé à le gêner des affaires
léon gaumont est un ingénieur surdoué
ces deux hommes que tout oppose et se
sont forgé une destinée commune dans une
perpétuelle surenchère ils ont bâti
chacun leur empire et dominer le monde
[Musique]
et
21h30 heure française soit il est
bienvenu en direct sur rt francs si vous
nous rejoignez après la hongrie la
slovaquie devient le deuxième pays
d'europe à utiliser spoutnik v
bratislava lancé hier sa campagne de
vaccination grâce au sérum russe qui
encore qui est encore en cours d'examen
à l'agencé européenne des médicaments
seules les personnes entre 18 et 60 ans
pourront recevoir ce rythme élevé selon
les autorités slovaques cyrielle bollée
spoutnik v gagne du terrain au sein de
l'union européenne après la hongrie
c'est au tour de la slovaquie
d'autoriser l'utilisation du vaccin
russe sur son sol depuis ce lundi ce
sont près de 5000 personnes qui se sont
déjà inscrits pour recevoir une dose de
sérum pourquoi je me vaccine parce que
ces russes voilà pourquoi rennes et
surtout ce n'est pas américain
je croise au vaccin moderna et files
heures mais on se pique nique
j'y crois un peu plus ça ne me dérange
pas qu'ils ne soient pas acceptés dans
d'autres pays
autorisé en slovaquie depuis le 1er mai
dernier
spoutnik vais peut être administré aux
personnes âgées de 18 à 60 ans une
limite d'âge que le vice premier
ministre igor matovic souhaite supprimer
8 points de vaccination ont été déployés
au sein du pays à commencer par les
régions de bratislava et 2 il y là les
quelques deux cent mille doses du vaccin
russes seront administrés uniquement sur
la base du volontariat
à ce jour nous avons une limite de 100
vaccination dont 85 personnes en ont
profité et 27 personnes ne se sont pas
présentés
cependant la vaccination avec ce vaccin
non enregistrés se fait directement à la
demande du patient
mais bien sûr la société assume les
conséquences en cas d'effets
indésirables de ce vaccin
nous allons essayer de satisfaire nos
citoyens est de vacciner tous ceux qui
se montrent intéressés du côté de moscou
les responsables russes se sont dits
optimistes ce vendredi il espère enfin
la reconnaissance prochaine de leurs
vaccins par l' agence européenne des
médicaments et l'organisation mondiale
de la santé et au brésil deux pays se
dirige vers une troisième bague de kobe
19 plus meurtrière encore que les
précédents selon certains
épidémiologistes en cause la lenteur de
la vaccination
levet précoce des restrictions ainsi que
la circulation active des variants le
brésil enregistre un des pires taux de
mortalité au monde et devrait atteindre
d'ici la fin du mois des cinq cent mille
morts depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire le pays d'amérique du sud n'a
jamais connu d'accalmie entre les
différentes vagues et pour en parler
nous sommes en direct depuis rio dé
janeiro avec chantal corcos médecin
généraliste au consulat français de la
ville c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
bonsoir chantal corcos merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france vous êtes
donc à rio tout d'abord comment vous ne
vous décririez la situation sanitaire
sur place écoutez les situations c'est
ici n'est pas je dirais plus
catastrophique et une l'été
en fait on a nous avons une augmentation
des cas mais curieusement est pas une
augmentation de la mortalité
c'est peut-être dû au fait que nous
avons une vaccination des personnes
âgées
jusqu'à peu près 59 ans ça représente
10% de la population c'est très très bas
très lente mais on atteint au moins de
mars les quatre mille et trois mille
morts par jour là on est à une moyenne
de 14 jours à 1500 1600 donc dire que on
y ont brillé possible qu'on reparte
non il est possible qu'on reparte mais
je veux dire actuellement on a en a eu
une occupation des lits de soins
intensifs ce à peu près entre 70% et 90%
sachant bien sûr que le brésil est grand
comme cinq fois la france dont vous avez
des disparités énormes entre les régions
où il ya plus de 80% de contaminer en
plus et d'autres où il ya moins 5% -1 %
tout dépend au caire et jour vous vous
placez en tout cas de certains
épidémiologistes alerte une troisième
bague encore plus meurtrière avons qu on
a du mal à s'imaginer comment ça peut
être encore plus meurtrier encore plus
grave au brésil vous vous y croyez à ces
à ses prédictions en tout cas ces
alertes extrêmement pessimiste écoutez
moi je suis médecin donc je suis je je
je je ferai quand les péniches privé un
jeu j'ai des collègues qui fréquentent
aussi les hôpitaux publics
alors qu'on voit une certaine
augmentation bea cyan hospitalisé
j'ai des patients moi-même hospitalisé
moins grave parce qu'ils ont à peu près
50 ans 40 ans joe spitz alizés il ya un
jeune homme de 27 ans qui restait 48
heures qui était limite donc voilà c'est
mon expérience non je n'ai pas deux pas
de boule de cristal
aujourd'hui oui aussi pardonnez moi de
vous couper
souvent on a critiqué la gestion de la
crise au brésil les mesures sanitaires
qui n'était pas forcément mise en place
et aussi la vaccination tout à la fois
aujourd'hui ou vraiment le problème
aujourd'hui c'est seulement 10% un peu
plus de 18% même la population qui est
immunisée c'est pas assez donc
certainement pas parce qu'il ya eu il ya
eu des achats 25 ils n'ont pas été fait
enfin 2020 signal qui est une commission
d'enquêté entendu qui aujourd'hui les
investigations sur quels sont les
ajustements les aboutissants de cette
affaire dont il ya tout une crise
politique autour de l'achat d'au delà de
la gestion de la stratégie vaccinale du
brésil alors que nourrit on a un réseau
assez intéressant c'est unique
la vaccination nous n'a pas les vaccins
achetées au moment donc on manque de
maxi n'ont réagi la population devant
cette gestion de l'épidémie qui
décidément plus d'un an avant le après
le début de l'épidémie qui est toujours
aussi poussif a aussi laborieuse oui
écoutez mal parce que tout de même nous
avons l'exemple de pays qui à partir du
moment où ils sont vaccinés ou dans des
conditions économiques meilleures 1
et ici nous sommes dans un pays en voie
de développement donc les conditions
économiques y sont très importantes
aussi importante que
que dans le monde entier et beaucoup de
personnes dépendent de leur travail
quotidien connaître à manger est sur la
table tous les jours il ya des gens qui
travaillent au jour non pas des salaires
du gagneur je vous dis et qui sont
obligés de sortir et de prendre des
transports se subsister et pourtant
c'est dans ce contexte que la copa
america de football comme du brésil doit
doit démarrer dimanche on a du mal à
l'imaginer
ici on est resté sous cloche voilà de
longs mois
c'est une décision éminemment politique
c'est encore un scandale politique
comme vous le dites si bien et en fait
il ya s'il ya une polarité brésil des
pour et des contres est il bon même si
les joueurs vont être testés tous les
clés toutes les 48 heures il n'est pas
dit qu'il nous amène pas avare y en as
commencé ici ne va rien en allemagne
hongrie du mec qu'elle c'est contagieux
imaginer qu'ils amènent le variant
indien gcc 100 femmes et en fait on a
comme un parent d'enfin les aucune
stratégie par rapport à la protection
des frontières au plus beaucoup en tout
cas shantala corcos un médecin
généraliste au consulat français de rio
de janeiro merci d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france et on part à
présent on ans après la vague épidémique
est qui a submergé le pays au mois de
mai certaines grandes villes
bombay ou encore new delhi ont allégé
leur restriction en tic au vide depuis
hier cependant la situation est loin
d'être sous contrôle
maxime hébert milles de son corps
abandonnés par leurs familles sur les
rives de la cauvery ce week-end dans le
sud du pays
paradoxe indien quarante huit heures
plus tard les rues de delhi et bombay
elles reprennent vie dans la capitale
économique du pays le taux de positivité
descendu sous le seuil des 5%
la région a été l'une des plus touchées
en mai elle voit ses centres commerciaux
cinéma bureaux et même salon de coiffure
rouvrir ce lundi avec des restrictions
nous avions l'habitude de gagner entre 3
et 4000 euros en un mois nous avons
ensuite subi une perte totale la plupart
des coiffeurs sont retournés dans leurs
villages
actuellement nous n'employons qu'un seul
coiffeur et la clientèle et si
nombreuses que nous ne pouvons pas la
contrôler à delhi le métro a repris à
50% de sa capacité et les marchands
ambulants sont de retour dans les rues
de la capitale les mois d'avril et de
mai ont été très très dur et très très
mauvais pour la région de la capitale
cependant voir le confinement s'alléger
le nombre de cas diminue et maintenant
que le nombre d'infections quotidienne
est inférieur à 500 j'ai le sentiment
que c'est très bon signe si les chiffres
officiels sont globalement positifs avec
cent mille nouveaux cas quotidiens
contre plus de 400 milles au mois de mai
dont les régions rurales les réticences
envers la vaccination freine la lutte
contre la pandémie nos concitoyens
meurthe ici malgré le fait que les gens
portent des masques et sont vaccinés le
gouvernement est il donc en mesure de
garantir que le vaccin est efficace s'il
est pourquoi les gens sont testés
positifs et meurt-il et s'il ne l'est
pas pourquoi la ministre qui loge ans
seuls 5 % des habitants de mon village
ont été vaccinées personnes de plus même
après l'ouverture d'un centre de
vaccination ici personne n'est prêt à
les autorités sanitaires et experts
médicaux craignent donc un retour à la
vie normale
trop brutale selon le ministre de la
santé au cours des 24 dernières heures
l'inde déplore 2427 morts mais ce
chiffre comme celui des nouveaux cas est
probablement sous-estimé
depuis le début de la pandémie l'inde
est le pays le plus touché derrière les
états unis avec près de 29 millions de
malades et plus de 346 milles morts
même si de nombreuses sources affirment
que leur nombre réel pourrait dépasser
deux millions ce lundi le premier
ministre n'a rennes drame audi a annoncé
la gratuité du vaccin pour tous les
adultes de 18 ans et plus alors que 13 %
de la population a déjà reçu sa première
dose en haïti toujours aucune solution à
la crise constitutionnelle que traverse
le pays depuis des mois un président
contesté qui fait machine arrière au
référendum illégal et illégitime pour
l'opposition et une majorité d'haïtiens
ainsi que des élections qui approchent
gré une insécurité croissante la
situation en haïti inquiète
maxime avait plongé depuis février dans
une crise politique et sociale
haïti ne s'en sort pas lancé par le
président joël moïse juste avant la
présidentielle et les législatives de
septembre
le référendum constitutionnel du 27 juin
qui devait proposer la suppression du
sénat et du poste de premier ministre a
finalement été repoussée officiellement
pour raisons sanitaires
cette décision est motivée par les
difficultés pour le conseil de
rassembler et de former l'ensemble du
personnel vacataire pour la réalisation
du scrutin
un nouveau calendrier électoral sera
établi après les recommandations des
autorités sanitaires et les avis
techniques des cadres de l'institution
électorale
si haïti est bien en état d'urgence
sanitaire pour l'opposition
joël moïse c'est tout simplement raviser
empêtré dans un processus électoral
illégitime illégal est impopulaire selon
m
elle exige désormais l'annulation pure
et simple de la procédure
impopulaire le président moïse les
depuis son élection en 2015 élu au
premier tour les questions autour de sa
légitimité se posait déjà malgré les
soupçons de fraude
moïse accède finalement au pouvoir en
2010 est près d'un an et demi après le
scrutin
la défiance de la population s'accroît
lorsque l'exécutif décide d'augmenter le
prix de l'essence de 38% en 2018
aujourd'hui pour bon nombre d'haïtiens
le président a endossé le costume de
dictateur lui qui dirige le pays par
décret sans contre-pouvoir depuis un an
et qui a déjà largement outrepassé la
fin de son mandat prévu pour février
l'article 134 points 2 de la
constitution haïtienne dit que le mandat
du président est terminée eh bien nous
avons un président qui est en rébellion
avec la loi qui est là pour défendre la
loi la justice
nous avons clairement dit que nous
sommes sous la dictature le peuple nous
a demandé de prendre la décision de
descendre dans la rue avec le peuple de
dieu pour faire entendre sa voix auprès
de la communauté internationale
début mai l'union européenne a refusé de
financer le référendum
quant aux états unis un temps proche du
président moïse il se déclare désormais
préoccupée quant au respect de la
démocratie dans le pays
sans aller beaucoup plus loin haïti doit
organiser des élections législatives et
présidentielle libres justes et
transparentes en 2021
le peuple haïtiens méritent le droit de
choisir ses dirigeants et d'avoir un
gouvernement qui est à son service
renforcé par la crise sanitaire et
institutionnel la pauvreté et
l'insécurité règnent désormais sur la
perle des antilles l'île des caraïbes
est gangréné par les gangs armés le mois
dernier sept religieux
deux français 5 haïtiens ont été enlevés
contre rançon ce dimanche des
commissariats ont été pris pour cible
par des bandes armées et des centaines
d'habitants ont dû fuir un quartier de
port-au-prince contrôlés par des gangs
tout proche
à seulement quelques mètres se trouvait
le palais présidentiel qui ressemble de
plus en plus à une coquille vide
et pour en parler nous sommes avec jean
marie théodat géographe spécialiste
d'haïti maître de conférences à
l'université panthéon sorbonne
bonsoir jean marie théodat merci d'être
avec nous leurs portes le référendum
pardon reportait c'est un mauvais signal
selon vous le référendum principe pour
moi plutôt un bon signal signe que le la
voix du peuple a été sinon clairement
entendu mais en tout cas interprété par
le gouvernement dans le sens de la
possibilité de la tenue de cette
consultation qui est comme vous l'avez
dit illégal impopulaire et surtout
inopportune parce que nous sommes dans
une période de recrudescence de la
pandémie de kovy 19 en haïti et ce n'est
vraiment pas le moment d'organiser des
meetings d'aller voter dans des espaces
qui ne sont pas véritablement prévu pour
recevoir des foules surtout qu'aucune
nouvelle date a été n'a été proposé ça
dit quoi
vu le temps extrêmement court qu'il
reste au président pour organiser le
référendum puis les élections
législatives et l'ancien les élections
présidentielles je pense que en fait il
s'agit d'une sorte de de reconnaissance
de de la défaite
vous faites de toute la stratégie qui
consistait à passer en force dans cette
année électorale
et finalement on peut on peut se
maintenant s'inquiéter de la façon dont
il va sortir du bois parce que le
gouvernement est quand même tenu
d'organiser des élections législatives
et présidentielle ça fait les affaires
de l'opposition qui aura davantage de
temps pour contester
procédure je pense que ça n'est ce pas
davantage de temps à l'opposition mais
ça donne surtout du fondement aux
revendications de l'eau passe tellement
de position les leçons de la population
de façon générale parce que l'opposition
n'est pas non plus à ce point unis au
point qu'on puisse dire qu'elle parle
d'une seule voix
mais néanmoins on peut dire que
l'atmosphère sociale va dans le sens
d'un rejet assez massif de la politique
du gouvernement et c'est ce que
l'annulation de ce scrutin vient
finalement concernés pourquoi
l'opposition était illégale cette
constitue cette constitution est fait de
façon d'abord que lé ne prévoit pas de
consultation de type référendaire entre
l'exécutif et la population ce qui est
une clause de sécurité par rapport à
tout dérapage populiste ou dictatoriale
du régime
donc c'est prendre le contre-pied des
garde-fous qui avait été prévu par la
constitution de 1987 pour empêcher le
retour au pouvoir des duvalier donc
c'est anticonstitutionnel
c'est illégal parce que cela se passe
dans une atmosphère où les deux chambres
haute et basse qui sont censés
représenter le pouvoir législatif et
faire contre eux contre pour
contrebalancer le pouvoir exécutif ne
sont pas en mesure de le faire parce que
les deux tiers de ces chambres ne sont
pas actuellement active et c'est une
mesure enfin qui est il légitime parce
que ce régime corrompu qui est largement
discréditée au sein de la population n'a
pas la légitimité pour organiser cette
consultation d'un mesure où ceux qui
sont considérés comme le problème du
pays ne peuvent pas en plus être la
solution
le président moïse sans contre-pouvoir
quelle marge de
manoeuvre at-il sa marge de manoeuvre
est extrêmement limitée d'un point de
vue légal
et d'un point de vue de point de vue
patriotique
on sent ce que à partir de l'année de
l'année prochaine ça dérange lié 2022
l'essence est passé la main à un
successeur dans l'intervalle il faudra
qu'il ait réalisé les élections
législatives
les élections présidentielles et nous
n'avons ni les moyens matériels ni la
paix civile nécessaire et dit surtout la
légitimité politique de ce gouvernement
pour organiser de telles élections donc
que tout laisse penser que nous allons
véritablement vers une impasse vers une
situation où ne pourront pas sortir de
la situation de l'impasse
constitutionnelle créé par le
gouvernement et donc il va continuer à
gouverner par décrets donc de facto nous
allons vers une dictature
que peut-on justement c'était pendant la
prochaine question que peut-on espérer
comme dénouement politique pour vous ces
dictatures ou rien est ce qu'il n'ya pas
un scénario plus optimiste
malheureusement le scénario le plus
réaliste c'est une nouvelle mise sous
tutelle de la souveraineté nationale
dans le cadre d'une mission de l'onu
mais cela s'est déjà vu à trois reprises
depuis la chute de la dictature des
duvalier donc n'avons pas grand espoir à
qu'andre de parler de bris expédiant et
il ne semble pas non plus que le
soulèvement populaire la contestation
dans les rues soient suffisantes pour là
pour faire tomber ce régime
donc en fait nous allons probablement
continuer à vivre d'escarmouches une
escarmouche comme cela se fait depuis
une dizaine d'années entre le
gouvernement et l'opposition
donc en fait le pays est en train de
faire du surplace merci jean marie
géographie humaine de conférences à
l'univers
c'était panthéon sorbonne merci d'avoir
été avec nous et c'est la fin de cette
émission prochain point complet sur
l'actualité ce sera dans quelques
minutes à 22h
[Musique]
un féminicide et commis tous les deux à
trois jours en france actuellement
pourquoi il joue ton encore à protéger
totalement les femmes on dit souvent aux
femmes
oser en parler briser le silence nous
savons que seulement 18 19 % des femmes
révèle les violences qu'elles subissent
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya 80% de femmes
qui ne révèle pas les violences qu'elles
subissent aux forces de sécurité dont
celle qui rêvait il faut vraiment les
croix et les protéger souvent on met
toute la responsabilité sur la victime
c'est la question de quels sont les
moyens que l'agresseur a mis en oeuvre
qui doit être posée et la loi le dis
très clairement
et souvent on détourne la loi par cette
histoire de consentement on voit bien
qu'on est quand même encore très loin
très loin de ce qui est nécessaire pour
vraiment pouvoir avoir les moyens de
protéger les femmes
bienvenue à novossibirsk nous sommes au
bord de la volga le plus long fleuve
d'europe
nous sommes chez vox harry
allons faire connaissance vous avez
choisi le jour là alors je suis arrivé
en 2005 pour étudier dernière poche leur
concept et en 2011 le monde manque pas
un petit peu non ah oui c'est tous les
fromages tous les soucis sont toutes les
les croissants la pâtisserie traits de
caractère des russes qui peuplaient
l'amitié les gens les gens très stylée
les français ne le savent pas je ne
pensais jamais de ma vie faire la cour
j'ai enseigné
vous pouvez me souhaiter bon courage
à très bientôt sur arte france
[Musique]
le théâtre du châtelet c'est pas un
théâtre comme les autres c'est un
théâtre qui est très diversifiée dans un
programmation la culture est une
activité absolument essentiel de notre
société de sa cohésion de sa cohérence
c'est aussi le rôle du châtelet de
pouvoir mettre en contact des très
belles productions avec le public
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans un théâtre en
plein confinement on a essayé de
réinventer notre métier et en
particulier on a fait beaucoup de
travail avec la télévision on a permis
de capter un certain nombre de
spectacles pour la télévision ce qui est
une autre manière de pouvoir créer la
relation avec le public et je suis sûr
qu'il y aura une grande volonté du
public de revenir dans les théâtres
[Musique]
le ms a exhorté certains pays africains
à ne pas détruire les vaccins anti covit
péri mais il faut craindre une
vaccination low cost en afrique lors une
vaccination reste une vaccination savez
la vaccination ce n'est pas elle va pas
commencer avec la guitare
le problème ça reste quand même
l'approvisionnement reste que c'est la
faute des pays les plus riches qui
accapare justement les productions de
l'accent où est le mécanisme de la
vaccination vous savez ça a soulevé
beaucoup d'enjeux sur la question de la
solidarité si on peut en faire plus en
terme de solidarité de partage
c'est quelque chose d'absolument
important on sait que le nigeria affirme
qu'il élabore son propre vaccin contre
le coc vie 19 pour en finir avec
justement la dépendance vis-à-vis des
laboratoires étrangers
que ce soit le sénégal le nigeria
l'afrique du sud beaucoup de pays ont
cette admission l'avoir amené l'agenda
de la santé publique au top des
priorités c'est quelque chose que nous
saluons énormément au niveau de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois vous êtes renversé par un homme
de 92 ans qui perd le contrôle de son
véhicule deux ans et demi plus tard vous
vous imposez comme un espoir français du
tennis fauteuil objectif est les jeux
paralympiques de paris y sommes
le sport m'a toujours sauver le tennis
et que c'est mon sport bon il ya un
fauteuil mais je vais essayer et en fait
je me suis rendu compte que ça allait
c'était suffisamment physique pour moi
j'ai une vie de sportif de haut niveau
je m'entraîne tous les jours c'est
devenu ma vie la raison de me lever le
matin j'avais toujours ce vieux rêve de
petite fille de faire du sport de ma vie
est finalement là c'est c'est ce que je
réalise avec le jambon m'en vais un
autre combat on ma vie qui est celui de
la sécurité routière s'agit d'un projet
de loi qui vise à mettre en place des
tests d'aptitude pour tous les
conducteurs pas seulement les seniors on
a un contrôle technique de son véhicule
il faut un contrôle technique de sa
personne et sa l'état doit doit imposer
loi sur ce sujet là
le président français avait annoncé
vouloir créer un commandement militaire
de l'espace l'espace est devenu
complètement clé en termes à la fois
militaire et en termes économiques
l'espace et est devenu un lieu de
confrontation potentiel je pense que
militarisation ça veut dire que
finalement il ya un risque pour l
assister à une guerre dans dans l'espace
oui la guerre est possible il ya de
multiples façons d'amener de rendre
inopérant effectivement des satellites
l'espace est encore un lieu pacifique
mais n'est plus que ça il peut devenir
effectivement un espace de confrontation
dans lequel des nations ou des groupes
peuvent intervenir pour détruire et et
causé des dommages considérables
[Musique]
la repentance est un sentiment aux
conséquences extrêmement graves pour
l'avenir
cette pratique obsessionnel s'impose
dans l'esprit de nos dirigeants comme la
condition incontournable d'une
gouvernance responsable moderne plutôt
que de se repentir
on ferait mieux de faire référence à un
passé dont on peut être fier nous
trouvons un autre exemple des limites de
cette transparence dans l'utilisation de
la raison d'état pour cacher la vérité
sous la pression médiatique et la raison
d'état on pratique une sélection du bien
et du mal à géométrie variable
il faut sauver la liberté d'expression
qui est prise en otage dans une
inversion entre le juste et le lien
[Musique]
emmanuel macron dénonce des faits isolés
d'individus ultra violent et rappelle la
nécessité de respecter les fonctions de
la république réaction quelques heures
après avoir été giflé par un homme lors
d'un déplacement dans la drôme cet après
midi deux hommes ont été interpellés
condamnation unanime de la classe
politique
[Musique]
kamala harris poursuit sa tournée en
amérique centrale premier déplacement à
l'étranger depuis son arrivée à la
maison blanche le bo était malade à bord
puis aujourd'hui le mexique avec la très
délicate question des migrations
clandestines
une visite de la vice-présidente
américaine censée s'appuyer sur la
promesse du président démocrate joe
biden d'adopter une politique migratoire
plus humaine que celle de donald rheault
dernière ligne droite de la
présidentielle au pérou le candidat de
la gauche radicale pedro castillo devant
sa rivale de la droite keiko fujimori
retournement de situation alors que la
quasi totalité des buts
ont été dépouillés résultats très serrés
attendu
[Musique]
il
bonsoir à tous merci nous rejoindre en
direct sur rt france elle des images
pour le moins inattendu en déplacement à
tain l'hermitage dans la drôme emmanuel
macron a reçu une gifle de la part d'un
homme lors d'un bain de foule
la classe politique de tout bord et
immédiatement réagi apporté son soutien
au président ont fait le point avec
notre reporter mona hameau dès lors
après son agression dans la drôme
emmanuel macron a préféré tempérer et
parle de faits isolés de personnes ultra
violente tout va bien il faut
relativiser à thiviers écoutez le le
peuple français est un peuple
républicain
l'écrasante majorité des français est
intéressé par les problèmes de fond sur
le principe je serai intraitable mais ne
laissons pas des faits isolés des
individus ultra violent comme il y en a
toujours quelques-uns dans les
manifestations aussi prendre possession
du débat public il ne le mérite pas pour
le moment deux individus ont été placés
en garde à vue après l'agression à
l'assemblée nationale jean castex le
premier ministre en a appelé à un
sursaut républicain écouter à travers le
chef de l'état c'est tout simplement la
démocratie qu'est viser la démocratie la
démocratie
mesdames et messieurs les députés
la démocratie et vous en est
l'illustration c'est le sait le débat
c'est le dialogue c'est la confrontation
d'idées c'est l'expression de désaccord
légitime
bien entendu mais ça ne peut en aucun
cas être la violence l'agression verbale
et encore moins l'agression physique
j'en appelle à un sursaut républicain
nous sommes tous concernés
il en va des fondements de notre
démocratie je vous remercie
alors vous l'imaginez les réactions
politiques sont unanimes tous condamnent
fermement l'agression du président de la
république vous propose de les écouter
cette fois-ci vous commencez à
comprendre que les violents passe à
l'acte je suis solidaire du président si
le débat démocratique peut être âpre il
ne serait en aucun cas tolérer la
violence physique
je condamne fermement l'agression
physique intolérable qui a visé le
président de la république
je condamne avec la plus grande fermeté
le geste inacceptable dont a été victime
emmanuel macron aucun des accords
politiques ne justifiera jamais la
violence le respect des institutions de
la république et de ses représentants
est en principe cardinal de notre vie
démocratique
exactement ce qu'est papa si tôt ça y
est vous la prenez au sérieux la
violence d'extrême droite maintenant
solidaire du président pour le moment
l'entourage du président de la
république tente de minimiser l'acte et
parle plutôt de tentatives de gif
d'ailleurs le président de la république
a continué sa journée comme si rien ne
s'était passé
ce n'est pas le premier président qui
est pris pour cible souvenez-vous en
nicolas sarkozy avait été attrapé
violemment par le col à brax cette
agression elle met encore une fois en
exergue la violence dénoncé par
plusieurs politiques ces derniers jours
en signe également que la crise sociale
et sociétale est encore exacerbée dans
notre pays et quelques mois avant et la
campagne présidentielle un maxime
thiébaut docteur en droit public nous a
fait part de son indignation
nations après la gifle reçue par le
président de la république on s'attaque
pas seulement un homme on s'attaque au
président de la république et le
président de la république c'est la clé
de voûte